Monka W.
Man könnte auch sagen Monka W in ordentlichen Sprachen.
Ich hab keinen Bock, Leute.
Und nicht aufs Streamen.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Ich hab keinen Bock.
Kickweight.
Moin, ihr erstens schon am Start.
Ja, das wird morgen auch wieder schlimm auf der Arbeit.
Da wünschen sich alle Leute immer.
Ja, und wie war es bei Weihnachten?
Und wie hast du Neujahr verbracht?
Und wir wünschen dir einfach...
Da krieg ich immer Anfälle, ey.
Ich bin nicht so der Gratulierer.
Ja, der Titel, der ist vertippt.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich hab noch nicht mal Bock, den Titel anzupassen.
Ja, genau.
Du hast schon genau erfasst.
Du weißt, um was es geht.
Ich hab absolut keinen Bock, morgen auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Ich hatte jetzt ein bisschen über einen Monat frei.
Jetzt muss ich wieder arbeiten gehen.
Ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock.
Was kann ich an der Arbeit legen?
Ich hatte nur...
Ich hab nie Bock.
Das legt sich die ersten paar Stunden dann wieder.
Aber ich hab nie Bock nach, wenn man einen Monat lang den Kreiselgrind des Todes machen kann,
dann wieder arbeiten zu gehen.
Sicherlich.
Wird sich der ein oder andere jetzt denken.
Max, beschwer dich nicht.
Du kannst zum größten Teil Homeoffice machen und hast nur vier Tage wochen.
Ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Da habt ihr recht.
Das ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Ist es auch nicht.
Aber es geht mir trotzdem auf den Sack.
Ich hab trotzdem keinen Bock.
Also im Prinzip ist es eigentlich egal, ja.
Keckweight.
Monka ist echt...
Ich mein, ich hab schon den ganzen Tag jetzt keinen Bock.
Aber jetzt, wo ich weiß, so demnächst muss ich dann mal pennen gehen.
Erst drei Stunden oder so muss ich mal pennen gehen.
Und morgen aufstehen, auf die Arbeit fahren,
hab ich überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ich hab mir's ja auch blöd vorgenommen.
Ich hab auch gesagt, ich fahr gleich den ersten Dienstag auf die Arbeit.
Wobei das gar nicht so schlimm ist.
Dann hab ich wenigstens die Woche gleich hinter mir.
Oh, nee.
Und das wird morgen schlimm.
Das wird morgen richtig schlimm auf der Arbeit.
Da sind sie sich alle wieder...
Weil das so der erste Tag ist, wo sie sich alle sehen.
Und Neujahr war und Weihnachten war und so.
Und so.
Da gratulieren sie sich dann alle immer einen halben Tag lang.
Und ihr wisst ja, wie ich auf solche Social-Sachen stehe.
Nee, Hände schütteln mach ich nicht.
Aber muss man sagen.
Und was hast du, was hast ich Weihnachten gemacht?
Und wie geht's dir?
Ich sag da einfach gar nix.
Ich sag da einfach so, ja, alles überlebt, passt schon.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ich hab halt keinen Bock auf solche Social-Sachen.
Wisst ihr doch.
Hä?
Ihr kennt mich doch.
Und die, mit denen ich zusammenarbeite, öfters mal, die kennen mich da in der Richtung auch schon.
Aber die anderen halt nicht.
Schreib ne Rund-Mail.
An was soll ich...
Soll ich an IT-Gesamt schreiben oder was?
Nee.
Und außerdem, das...
Guck mal, selbst wenn ich ne Mail schreib, meinst du, das hält davon ab, dass die Leute das alle sagen?
Nö.
Außerdem, bin doch nicht blöd, schreib ne Mail.
Da denken die Leute doch, ich will da drüber reden.
Hast du in Dubai im Penthouse bei Apporet oder wo?
Ähm.
Ja, glücklicherweise, glücklicherweise, hab ich den Eindruck, geht's nicht ganz so lang.
Das ist meistens...
Ja.
Das, das, das Gute ist, das Gute ist, wenn ich morgen nach Frankfurt fahr, dann bin ich so, keine Ahnung, halb neun oder so, bin ich da.
Ich übertreib's ja nicht mehr, ich steh ja nicht mal fünf vor 45 auf wie früher, ne, muss ich ja nicht mehr übertreiben.
Äh, ich bin dann halb neun da.
Dann sind noch nicht so viele andere da.
Guck ich mir mal das neue Büro an.
Wir haben nämlich ein neues Büro gekriegt.
Während ich weg war, hab ich mitgekriegt.
Da hab ich sogar jetzt einen richtig, echten, eigenen Platz.
Die ganze Zeit im alten Büro hatte ich ja keinen, das war zu klein.
Was ja nicht schlimm war, ich hab immer auf so einer Wechselarbeitsplatzfläche gesessen.
Was mir persönlich sogar lieber ist, ich mag das, wenn da so täglich die Leute so ein- und ausgehen irgendwie.
Ich mag so Wechselarbeitsplätze, Flächen.
Was ich auch mag ist, dass die Leute ihre Plätze nicht dekorieren,
sondern dort ist halt am Ende des Tages...
muss der Platz wieder aufgeräumt sein.
Und das mag ich, das gefällt mir.
Ich hab noch, ich hab noch nicht mal ne Schublade, ich hab im Schrank, hab ich ein Fach,
da leg ich immer meine Maus und Tastatur rein, mehr brauch ich nicht.
Der Rest ist im Rucksack.
Und was brauch ich schon?
Ich brauch mein Notebook, ich brauch mein Handy und ich brauch ein Ladekabel.
Okay, die Eintrittskarte brauch ich noch, ja.
Das war's, fertig.
Mehr, mehr muss es nicht sein.
Hm, ja.
Aber, es wird halb so wild, ich hab immer nur keinen Bock den Tag, bevor ich arbeiten muss, da drauf.
Aber sobald ich dann da bin und so, oder eigentlich schon, sobald ich aufgestanden bin, ist das gar nicht so wild.
Ja, also, es ist jetzt nicht super schlimm, ich kenn das ja schon, aber ich hab halt trotzdem keinen Bock.
Ich mein, man kann sich das vorstellen, man braucht bestimmt ne Woche, wobei, ganz ehrlich, eigentlich nicht.
Ich wollt grad sagen, man braucht ja immer...
Man braucht ja immer ein bisschen, bis man sich dran gewöhnt hat, jetzt frei zu haben, oder braucht man ein bisschen, sich da dran zu gewöhnen, bis man, dass man wieder arbeiten muss, aber das Freihaben geht bei mir sehr schnell, die Gewöhnung, und umgedreht geht's aber auch sehr schnell.
Einfach, einfach mal ins Büro gesetzt und schon ist es wieder gut.
Ne.
Weder das eine noch das andere, ich trink keinerlei Energydrinks, ich trink auch keine, keine Cola, Fanta oder Kaffee.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der einzige IT-Dude, der kein, kein Kaffee trinkt.
Hoodie hab ich auch selten nur noch an.
Guck, aber...
Vielleicht zieh ich tatsächlich morgen eins an.
Was kann man eigentlich anziehen, Leute?
Außer Hoodie und Hemd.
Gibt's da noch sowas dazwischen?
So ein Pulli vielleicht?
Ohne, also quasi in ein Hoodie ohne Hood.
Wenn die Bahn kommt, oh ja, oh je, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Jetzt sagst du was.
Jetzt, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Bahn?
Jetzt sagst du was, ich muss mal gucken.
Irgendwas, ist, wie sieht's eigentlich mit, mit Streik und so aus?
Bahnstreik droht im Januar.
24 rein.de, okay.
Der Westen.de.
Gibt's da nicht, gibt's da nicht irgendwas?
Okay, der Westen.de meinetwegen.
Die Seite, die Seite sieht ja schon grausam aus, ja.
Außerdem übelst, übelste Flashbang.
Ja, deutsche Bahn, Kunden müssen schlucken.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Alter, was ne Überschrift, was ne Überschrift, Alter.
Der Weihnachtsfrieden läuft ab.
Ja, wisst ihr was, ganz ehrlich, wenn die, wenn die wie verrückt streiken, dann mach ich halt einfach mehr Homeoffice, was willst du machen?
Ich hab ja, also wenn ich keine Chance hab hinzukommen, hab ich keine Chance.
Klassisches Büro ausführt, Big, Big, Herren hochgeschnittene, was für ein Ding?
Ah ja, das, mh.
Das ist exzellent dafür.
Ja.
Ich wollte aber gerade gucken, was die Bahn.
Morgen macht.
Lasst mich mal kurz schauen.
Hanau.
Dann ist die.
Was, was die Bahn hat mir für einen Scheiß vorschlägt.
Von Hanau zum nächsten Tegut.
Warum, warum schlägt das die Bahn-App vor?
Gibt da überhaupt keinen Sinn?
Aha, ich seh schon, erster Zug ist cancelled.
Erster Zug ist cancelled.
Allerdings jetzt.
Allerdings jetzt und nicht morgen früh.
Lass mich mal kurz, ähm.
Pilter, ne, Uhrzeit.
Die neue Bahn.
Die neue Bahn-App ist auch keine wirkliche Ausgeburt der Usability.
So, machen wir mal 7 Uhr 30 einfach.
Da weiß ich, dass in dem Dreh immer was fährt.
Hm?
Ähm.
Ne, scheint, scheint bis jetzt zumindest nichts auszufallen.
Okay.
Ja.
Die haben garantiert viele tolle Überraschungen vorbereitet, von denen sie selbst jetzt noch nichts wissen.
Das ist ja das Beste.
Die sind immer.
Die Bahn ist immer selbst.
Überrascht von ihren Sachen.
Und auf der anderen Seite bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass die sich zu vielen Sachen, wo sie von überrascht sind, was ausdenken, so als wüssten sie, was Sache ist.
So.
Von Notarzteinsatz am Gleis, Böschungsbrand, Verspätung eines vorausfahrenden Zuges, Personalmangel.
Ich glaube ganz ehrlich, diese ganzen Gründe, die dort immer gesagt werden, die stimmen halt zum größten Teil gar nicht.
Es wird einfach.
Randomized irgendwas gesagt, weil es ist doch auch, zumal es jetzt mal Seriously ist, ist auch scheißegal, oder es ist vollkommen egal, was die sagen, mir ist es mich Facts ab, egal, ob das ein Böschungsbrand ist, ein Notfalleinsatz oder ein vorausfahrender Zug, der zu langsam ist, es ist mir scheißegal, es ist, es ist zu spät, der Rest ist mir egal, warum, warum die haben den Ausreden Champ bei sich programmiert, intern, das glaube ich auch.
Aber wisst ihr, das ist, das ist, das ist mir doch sowas von.
So was von wurscht, weshalb das zu spät ist, die sollen das lieber machen, wie in Tokio, wo der Typ, wenn es zwei Minuten Verspätung hat, sich öffentlich entschuldigt, wenn es nochmal Verspätung hat, er zurücktritt.
Ich weiß nicht, was passiert in Japan, wenn, wenn die Bahn dreifach Verspätung hat unter dem gleichen Chef, ob der dann irgendwie, weiß ich, vom Hochhaus springen muss oder so, keine Ahnung, die sind da einfach relativ hart drauf.
Aber da sind ja schon Leute zurückgetragen, wenn ein paar, wegen ein paar Minuten.
So pünktlich, wer hier auch da ist.
Also, die Bahn ist da auch garantiert wieder.
Ich hab mich überrascht von ihrem Scheiß, man.
Naja.
Die haben da in Japan halt noch ein ganz anderes Pflichtbewusstsein, was das angeht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ganz ehrlich, die Trittfirmen sind sicherlich nicht das Hauptproblem, warum es bei der Bahn nicht funktioniert.
Hattet ihr damals in der Schule auch immer so blöde Diskussionen?
So nach dem Motto.
Also, Bus, Bus ist nicht gekommen oder sowas.
Und da kam die Lehre immer an, so nach dem Motto, ja, aber ohne, dass das irgendwie schriftlich bestätigt ist und so.
Ey, das ging mir immer so auf den Sack.
Also, ich bin zum größten Teil auch zur Schule gelaufen oder damals tatsächlich schon vereinzelt mit dem Fahrrad gefahren, weil ich nie viel Fahrrad gefahren bin früher.
Ich bin tatsächlich meistens zur Schule gelaufen, manchmal aber mit dem Bus.
Und immer, wenn irgendwas, also je nachdem, von wo, ja, von daheim oder vom Opa.
Und je nachdem, es war halt immer jetzt.
Irgendwann habe ich mir eingedacht, ich meine, ich war so selten zu spät, ja.
Und wenn dann was war, habe ich mir gedacht, naja, dann trag mich halt als fehlend ein.
Who cares?
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Also, bei uns, bei uns in der Schule hatten sie so ein Käfig für die Fahrräder.
Der wurde nur zweimal am Tag dann aufgeschlossen unter Aufsicht.
Oder nee, nur in der Pause aufgeschlossen nach Aufsicht.
Irgendwie sowas oder nach Stundenende.
Und dann stand dann immer einer und hat geguckt, dass die Fahrräder nicht kaputt gemacht werden.
Wenn ihr überlegt, das war bei mir.
Das war bei mir schon so.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie das heute ist.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie es an irgendeiner Problemschule in Berlin zur heutigen Zeit ist.
Da traut sich wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr mit dem Fahrrad hin.
Weil die sicher sind, das Fahrrad ist danach weg oder kaputt.
Egal, wie alt und schrottig das Fahrrad ist, es ist danach noch schrottiger.
Welche Länder in der Statistik...
Oh, Moment.
Moment, was?
Wir haben...
Oh, es gibt eine Statistik zur Pünktlichkeit im Bahn...
Bahnverkehr...
Ne, ne, ne.
Pff.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass die Geld verdienen müssen, aber...
Bezahlen will ich dafür jetzt trotzdem nix.
Ist ja fast schon wie bei den Kokonas.
Wo teilweise Metalldetektoren...
Oder ist es da teilweise auch schon so schlimm, dass die in Berlin an den Schulen Metalldetektoren brauchen,
dass die Leute keine Messer und Sachen mitbringen?
Ich meine, das ist doch wirklich schon echt dann komplett vorbei alles.
Also, da würde ich auch nicht freiwillig als Lehrer...
Arbeiten mehr.
Bei dir zeigt es sich nichts mit Bezahlen an.
Vielleicht bist du eingeloggt oder so schon.
Vielleicht bist du eingeloggt?
Vielleicht muss man...
Vielleicht muss man sich inkogniton...
Äh.
Ne.
Vielleicht muss ich Linux verwenden, die wissen, dass das besser ist.
Äh.
Okay, keine Chance.
Ich muss mich einloggen.
Nope.
No pass.
Geht nicht.
Egal.
Letztendlich ist es mir auch egal, wie es in anderen Ländern aussieht, was die Bahnpünktlichkeit angeht.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass viele noch schlechter sind und viele noch besser sind.
Was mich interessiert, ist das, wofür es für mich relevant ist.
Und das ist halt hier, ne.
Und da ist laufend irgendwas.
So, Reboot.
Oh, guck mal, habt ihr das gesehen?
Der Pepo ist schon fast am Schlafen.
Ja.
Ey, aber ich sag euch, das ist wirklich kacke, ne.
Wenn ihr einen Monat...
Morgens aufstehen konntet.
Mal ein bisschen Sport gemacht habt und dann den ganzen Tag Kreisel kreint.
Und jetzt müsst ihr morgens aufstehen.
Einmal die Woche zumindest nach Frankfurt fahren.
Und allgemein arbeiten.
Dann fuckt das schon irgendwie ab, ja.
Bist du gestern auch um 10 im Bett gewesen?
Ne.
Quatsch, wie kommst du da...
Hä?
Ach so.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Du meinst, weil ich sonst auch immer ins Bett gehe?
Na ja.
Also erstens bin ich...
Die letzten Tage auch nicht immer um 10 ins Bett gegangen.
Also ich bin zwar immer...
Ich orientiere mich da drum.
In Wirklichkeit gehe ich ja meist eher so 23 Uhr oder so ins Bett.
Gerade Dezember, wenn ich frei habe.
23 Stunden.
Gestern bin ich, keine Ahnung, 0 Uhr, 0 Uhr 30 oder so ins Bett.
Was ist Simmax?
Ich traue mich, das nicht aufzumachen.
Auch wenn es eigentlich nichts Schlimmes sein kann.
Weil das mal ein Streaming ist.
Aha.
Da steht nichts drin.
Auch geil.
Österreicher sind pünktlich.
Pünktlich, ja.
Man muss aber sagen, vielleicht faken die einfach nur ihre Bahnstatistik besser.
Weil bei uns sind die offiziellen Bahnstatistiken ja auch massiv, massiv geschönt.
Nix F.
Läuft alles wunderbar hier, der Stream.
Guck, keine Package Lost und sonst was.
Die rechnen sich das ja schön.
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, die Bahn, die schafft es tatsächlich.
Die kann, die Bahn macht ihre eigenen Statistiken mehr oder weniger und faket schon zu Recht, was Sache ist und sind trotzdem immer richtig krass unter den sich selbst und die selbst gesteckten Ziele sind schon zu niedrig.
Ja, also die sind wirklich, es ist echt lächerlicher Verein.
Deswegen bin ich froh, dass ich so gut um die jetzt mittlerweile drumherum komme.
Einmal die Woche muss ich hinfahren.
Und das halt, das ertrage ich gerade so.
Wenn es auch echt abfuck ist.
Jedes Mal, wenn was ist und ich meine, ich sehe es ja auf Twitter.
Ja, ich, ich kann mich da mittlerweile auch nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Das ist, es war einfach schon zu oft zu viel Bullshit bei der Bahn.
Ich kann mich, ich kann mich da mittlerweile nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Also wenn ich, wenn ich rein rechtlich gesehen könnte, so dass es nicht echt schon fast illegal ist, was man schreibt, dann würde ich die sogar noch heftiger flamen.
Wenn ich könnte, wenn ich, wenn ich öffentlich, wenn ich dürfte, würde ich ihn noch härter flamen.
Also es gibt, glaube ich, nichts, was ich so sehr hasse auf der Welt, wie die Bahn.
Ja, mache ich.
Wobei noch stimmt ja nicht.
Es ist ja wieder seit 2013 wieder.
Oder meinst du dazu?
Also seit 2013, ja, also immer noch.
Und es sind immer 2013 schon elf Jahre, gell?
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Ich bin jetzt 14 Jahre auf YouTube.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Gut, ich meine, so viele Videos.
Ich habe die letzten, ich habe die ersten drei Jahre so viele Videos hochgeladen wie die letzten zehn Jahre zusammen vielleicht, aber trotzdem schon ganz schön lang.
Eigentlich habe ich ja geplant, im Dezember mehr mehr zu streamen, wobei das ging eigentlich, aber vor allem mehr Videos zu machen.
Da kam mir leider der MMO Kreiselgrind dazwischen.
Der war zu strong.
Ich habe gesehen, der Fabian ist auch am MMO Kreiselgrinden.
Ich war vorher beim Frasier im Stream.
Und der grindet irgendwelche komischen Weep Games.
Und er spielt tatsächlich, jetzt haltet euch fest, MW2, äh sorry, nein, MW3 2020 Multiplayer.
Ja, da können wir nicht zusammen spielen, aus mehreren Gründen.
Erstens, weil ich das Spiel nicht habe.
Ich würde es mir vielleicht kaufen, weil wir öfters zusammen spielen können.
Aber der ist halt immer schon spät da, wenn ich eigentlich schon nicht mal da bin.
Also es passt eigentlich, passt halt nicht.
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe die meisten, also auch das letzte, dieser, wie heißt denn das dort, Developer Showcase Dinger gesehen.
Ja, mein Problem ist, das Spiel ist halt auch schon so lange angekündigt und so lange in Entwicklung.
Dass ich immer noch leicht skeptisch bin, ob es, auch wenn es ja anscheinend immer mal regelmäßig Progress macht, ob das wirklich jemals rauskommt.
Ich meine, hey, es kommt wahrscheinlich ja raus als Camelot Unchained.
Camelot Unchained kommt nie raus.
Also da haben sie sich verkalkuliert.
Haben wir, haben wir zufälligerweise, Chat, haben wir irgendwelche, ich weiß, das ist ziemlich Nische, aber vielleicht haben wir ein paar und ich habe ja auch ein paar mal.
Da auch gestreamt und alte Dark Leute haben sich ja gefreut auf Camelot Unchained.
Haben wir irgendwelche Camelot Unchained Backer hier gerade dabei?
Also ich habe das damals gebackt.
Also das hier, ich kann es einfach mal zeigen.
Das hier.
Nein, nein, nein.
Kickstarter.
Ja, also das hier, das habe ich ja mal gebackt vor zehn Jahren oder so.
Keine Ahnung, fragt mich nicht.
Und ich habe das intern.
Und ich habe das internal Beta-Testing Tier gewählt, weil ich mir gedacht habe, oh cool, Dark Nachfolger und jetzt intern testen mit, so mega geil.
Habe ich, habe ich gebackt?
Wartet mal, ich muss mal aufpassen, dass ich nicht über mein Headset fahre.
Sekunde, was hier?
Okay, viel besser.
So, und das war ja ursprünglich geplant.
Ich glaube, Release war scheduled für 2016 oder so.
2016 oder so.
Das muss, glaube ich, Release sein.
Und jetzt haben wir 2024.
Das ist schon über zehn Jahre.
Und die haben mittlerweile auch aufgehört, hier irgendwas zu posten.
Ich glaube, hier gibt es auch nichts mehr, oder?
Außer, dass die Leute ein bisschen pisst sind.
Und es lädt schon gar nicht mehr.
Ja, 2000, 2015 haben sie das letzte Update gepostet.
Na ja, also.
Da kommt Ashes of Creation auf jeden Fall eher raus als Camelot Unchained.
Ich muss aber den mal zumindest zugute halten.
Also, das Geld ist weg.
Das werde ich nie wieder sehen.
Ist im Prinzip auch immer mit dem Risiko verbunden.
Schade um das Game.
Das Ding ist, im Vergleich zu anderen Kickstarter-Scams gehe ich davon aus, dass die nicht von Anfang an Leute scammen wollten.
Sie haben es einfach organisatorisch in den Sand gesetzt.
Geben es aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht zu.
Und wisst ihr was?
Achso, ja, Refunds machen sie auch nicht.
So, und ich weiß, es gibt ein paar Fanboys, gerade auf Reddit.
Auf Reddit, es gibt ein Subreddit für das Game.
Da postet einmal im Monat einer was.
Aber es gibt total viele Fanboys, die da immer noch des Übels verteidigen.
Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Jetzt sagt mir mal, Leute.
Ein Spiel, was über zehn Jahre in Entwicklung ist.
Was würdet ihr dort in Newslettern erwarten?
Okay, nichts.
Steht noch nicht mal was drin.
So, Newsletter.
Man sieht nach zehn Jahren Entwicklung, sieht man Concept Arts.
Die können nichts zeigen von diesem Game, Alter.
Concept Arts.
Nach über zehn Jahren.
Fuckin' Concept.
Oh, oh.
Wir haben ingame, was aussieht wie 2005-Grafik.
Nice.
Es ist halt echt lächerlich, einfach nur noch.
Ihr könnt euch fast vorstellen, dass diese Post-KI generiert sind.
Ach.
Das tut es mir echt um das Game, beziehungsweise drum leid, was es hätte werden können.
Da kommt nie was raus.
Der Zug ist abgefahren.
Muss ich, muss ich abschreiben.
Was aber auch nicht so wild ist.
Ich mein ganz im Ernst.
Ich spiel Dark aktuell auf nem Freeshot.
Und das ist die beste Version, die es je gegeben hat.
Also besser als live und besser als es damals gewesen ist.
Insofern.
Ich kann auch ohne Probleme noch 20 Jahre ein jetzt schon 20 Jahre altes Game spielen.
Ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann ist das Game, dann ist das Game halt dann 40 Jahre alt.
Wen juckt's?
Es sieht jetzt schon alt aus.
In 20 Jahren sieht's halt noch älter aus.
Aber es interessiert mich ja nicht großartig.
Und es gibt ein paar Verrückte, die versuchen die Dark Assets in Unreal zu importieren.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob da was rauskommt.
Ich kann's mir nicht vorstellen, weil
neben Assets importieren und Game-Logik
sind ja noch zwei komplett paar unterschiedliche Schuhe.
Naja.
Leider ins Klo gegriffen hier mit dem ganzen Kickstarter-Stelz hier.
Aber ich hätt's mir halt nice vorgestellt.
Aber ist halt nicht.
Sascha, danke für den Sub.
Und ansonsten.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hab in letzter Zeit nichts mehr auf Kickstarter gemacht.
Ich hab ein paar Sachen gebackt.
Von der sich selbst reinigenden Hose.
Hab ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Und Camelot Unchained hab ich auch erzählt.
Zwei Sachen, wo ich mehrere hundert Euro in Sand gesetzt hab.
Und die anderen Sachen weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Das war nichts Großartiges.
Fällt gar nichts mehr ein, außer den zwei Sachen.
Ja, man merkt sich immer nur die Sachen, die schlecht sind.
Ja.
Aber ich hab die letzten Jahre nichts mehr auf Kickstarter gemacht.
Ganz ehrlich, es ist einfach...
Ich warte, bis die Sachen rauskommen.
Ja, das ist das Ding.
Mir fällt nichts ein.
Mir fällt außer den zwei Sachen, die es richtig kacke gelaufen ist,
fällt mir grad gar nichts ein.
Da müsst ihr mich hier nebenbei vom Kickstarter-Account einloggen.
Ja.
Und...
Ich hab die letzten Jahre über Abstand vom Kickstarter gehalten.
Genauso wie von Early-Access-Spielen.
Mich stört's auf Steam immer noch, dass man auf Steam nicht komplett und gut filtern kann,
dass keine Early-Access-Sachen angezeigt werden.
Du kannst zwar manche Sachen so ein bisschen filtern,
aber so dieses...
Zeigt mir in nichts von Steam Early-Access an, gibt es nicht.
Also du hast immer noch...
Die Liste für dich oder sowas, ja?
Klickst du durch, denkst du, ey, sieht ja ganz interessant aus, machst du auf...
Aha, Early-Access.
Du weißt, dass ich da richtig drauf stehe.
Aufsicht 3000 war frohes Neues und frohe Weihnachten und alles Gute zum Geburtstag
und hast nicht gesehen zu wünschen, gell?
Ja, wenn du Early-Access auf Steam filtern würdest,
dann ist wahrscheinlich wirklich 90% raus mittlerweile.
Was meint ihr?
Statistisch gesehen.
Was meint ihr, wenn man es mal rein prozentual sich anguckt,
wie viele Early-Access-Games,
die quasi als Early-Access-Game auf Steam an den Start gehen,
werden jemals fertig?
Und mit fertig meine ich nicht wirklich zu Ende entwickelt,
sondern dass sie offiziell aus dem Early-Access raus sind.
Wie viel Prozent?
30?
Oder weniger oder mehr?
Was sagt ihr?
Was meine ich?
Also...
Minus 5, ja?
Fühlt sich zumindest so an.
Aber Factorio war, glaube ich, auch mal Early-Access und ist aus dem Early-Access raus.
Und es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr.
Also, es gibt ja durchaus die einen oder anderen.
Oder...
Dieses...
Das eine Dungeon-Keeper...
Remake kann man nicht sagen.
Das...
Neuauflage, die nicht Dungeon-Keeper heißt, ist auch aus dem Early-Access raus.
Also...
Okay, ihr meint 30% ist noch zu viel.
Ja, eher 15.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, vielleicht 15.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall...
Wenig.
Popke war auch mal Early-Access, richtig.
Ja.
Wobei ich da sagen muss...
Bei manchen Spielen...
Ist es ja irgendwie mittlerweile auch so...
Gehört schon fast zum Running-Gag.
Ich meine...
Man darf nicht vergessen...
Dota 2 ist, glaube ich, immer...
Was?
Die Beta ist over?
Ich dachte...
Ich dachte Dota ist offiziell immer noch Beta.
Ist es nicht?
Ich dachte, da steht immer noch Beta dran.
Ich...
Weil...
Ich meine, es gehört ja mal eine Zeit lang zum guten Ton, dass an irgendwelchen Spielen
noch Beta immer dran...
Das haben sie auch ewig dran stehen lassen.
Ja.
Ja, Popke...
Das muss ich echt sagen.
Auch wenn es echt nicht mal ein Game war, habe ich den Eindruck, dass das ganz gut läuft.
Vor allem...
In Asien und in Korea muss Popke richtig gut sein.
Also...
Von den...
Von den Spielern her.
Ja.
Von den...
Von den Spielerzahlen her.
Also...
Popke war ja mal eine Zeit lang, glaub sogar vor Fortnite und Apex und dem ganzen Zeug.
Also, Popke, ist gerade in Korea und so, mega beliebt gewesen zwischenzeitlich.
Ich hab einmal den Fehler gemacht und habe mir einen E-Spot, ein Popke-E-Sport-Tournament
angeguckt...
Oder zumindest, nicht ein Tournament, ein Spiel.
Popke-E-Spot.
Leute.
Das war, seriously, das war glaube ich vier gegen...
Oder was?
Vierer Squad ist es, gell?
Relativ sehr war das.
Vierer Squad.
Und das war so.
unglaublich langweilig.
Die sind den ganzen Tag nur irgendwie rumgestelzt
und am Ende haben sie ein paar Kills gemacht.
Also da gucke ich mir tatsächlich lieber Warzone an
von irgendwelchen Streamern, die versuchen,
60 plus Killgames zu machen oder so.
Das war so abfuck langweilig.
Puppke eSport.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste daran war?
Gar nicht so sehr, dass die so gespielt haben.
Ich meine, die spielen halt so optimiert,
was die Regeln hergeben.
Wenn die Regeln hergeben, es zählt, wer die Runde gewinnt.
Winner, Winner, Chicken Dinner.
Und nicht, weil die meisten Kills machen.
Kein Wunder, dass die alle rumchillen.
Was viel schlimmer war,
waren die Caster.
Die Caster mussten die ganze Zeit versuchen,
das irgendwie zu hypen, was dort passiert.
So, it's getting intense, it's getting intense.
Und ich denke mir so, Alter, die liegen im Gras
und haben anderen Spieler gesehen.
Das ist jetzt schon intense, oder was?
Also, die lagen halt im Gras alle
und haben sich da rumgerobbt und haben mal initial gelootet
und lagen halt die ganze Zeit nur rum.
Und dann hat mal ein Spieler einen anderen Spieler gespottet.
Nicht geschossen, einfach nur gesehen, ja?
Und dann sind die Caster ausgeflippt.
Oh, it's getting intense, it's getting hot.
Mann, der Typ liegt halt einfach nur rum.
Und dann ging es weitere fünf Minuten,
wo nur rumgelegen wurde.
Also, es war wirklich das langweiligste E-Sport-Game,
was ich je gesehen habe überhaupt, Puppke.
Weiß nicht, ob sich die Regeln da mittlerweile geändert haben,
dass es nicht mehr so...
So, nennen wir es mal nett umschrieben, slow-paced ist.
E4 ESL.
Ja, stimmt, das wurde ja mal kurz gespielt.
Was ist eigentlich, jetzt wo du gerade sagst,
Battlefield 4 ESL E-Sport,
was ist jemals was aus Battlefield...
Wie hieß das denn?
Recursion oder so.
Incursion?
Recursion?
Irgendwie so...
Was ist denn da draus geworden?
Die hatten doch mal versucht, so einen...
E-Sport-Battlefield-Multiplayer-Part rauszubringen.
Das ist komplett im Sande verlaufen, oder?
Hat keine Sau interessiert, hat keiner gespielt
und wurde dann quasi auch, ja, einfach nicht weiterentwickelt.
Ist das nicht Recursion oder so?
Incursion?
Battlefield 1 Incursion, ja genau.
Competitive Match.
Ja, das hat sich nirgendswohin entwickelt.
Gibt es eigentlich...
Jetzt war ich aber gerade dabei,
deswegen habe ich mich schon lange nicht mal mit Geschäft beschäftigt.
Gibt es eigentlich...
einen Plan
für Battlefield 2042
dieses Jahr?
Dunkles Protokoll, kann man das auch irgendwie auf Englisch stellen?
Chat, gibt es...
Wo ist der offizielle Knopf hier?
Führen wir das auf da?
Man kann es hier oben zwar auch ändern,
aber es muss ja da eigentlich mal einen Button für geben.
Kann es sein,
dass Battlefield immer noch weniger
Maps hat, als Battlefield 4 zu launchen.
Es könnte sein, dass wir jetzt ungefähr
die Launch-Anzahl erreicht haben.
Definitiv nicht,
wie bei Battlefield 4 und Battlefield 3
nach einem Jahr, wo die ganzen DLCs
da durch waren.
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Also eins muss man ja sagen,
die machen immer auch sehr viel Text
um wenig.
Mal gespannt, wie es 2024 aussieht,
ob wir demnächst Battlefield kriegen oder nicht.
An die Chancen...
Ja, man weiß es ja nicht, ne?
Sind ja...
Sagen wir mal so,
sind wahrscheinlich schon gering auf ein neues Battlefield
und sind wahrscheinlich noch deutlich geringer
auf ein gutes Battlefield.
Ne, Hardline hat keiner vergessen.
Spielt bloß keiner mehr.
Die meisten Leute, die da waren,
als das rausgekommen ist,
können sich durchaus noch an Hardline erinnern.
Hardline war auch mal ganz nice für ein paar Runden,
hat aber extrem schnell die...
Tja...
Ich will jetzt noch nicht mal sagen, Faszination.
Die Anziehung verloren.
Ja.
Und dann war es ziemlich, ziemlich schnell dead.
Ich meine, wir können ja mal just for fun gucken.
Ähm...
Server?
Ja.
Hey!
Immerhin!
Leute, einen Server gibt es noch!
Hotwire.
Downtown.
Ich meine, wir haben immerhin einen...
Hier ist noch nicht mal was gesetzt großartig.
Äh...
Ich meine, es gibt immerhin einen Server und...
Na gut, man sieht es hier relativ genau, 65 aktive Spieler.
Wie sieht das bei Battlefield...
Wie sieht es eigentlich bei Venice Unleashed aus?
Hat da mal wieder einer reingeguckt in letzter Zeit?
Keck, keck, wait.
Haben die ihre Crashes wieder gefixt?
Na, immerhin!
Immerhin!
Guckt mal da!
Bei Battlefield 3 sitzt immerhin...
Immerhin kannst du da...
Guck mal da!
Immerhin!
immerhin, immerhin kannst du
TDM, Nosha, Candles
Only, was sonst?
Was sonst? Ja.
Das Problem mit dem Reality-Mod ist, dass
das auch niemand spielt.
Ich hab das am Anfang
mir angeguckt, hab mir gedacht,
okay, das dauert schon ein bisschen, bis man da reinkommt.
Aber im Endeffekt, ich hatt's dann nach
drei, vier Monaten oder so
nach Release nochmal aufgemacht, da war im Prinzip keiner
mehr eingeloggt. Also
Nosha, Candle,
Bitsku,
Zapp, Bep,
was auch immer.
Die
Commodots werden's wissen.
All Maps, Recruiting,
der TBG-Clan,
den gibt's auch gefühlt überall, oder?
Die haben auch Back Company 2
Server und sowas.
Also, ich mein, immerhin.
Kann man noch
Rush gescheit spielen, irgendwo noch?
So als bester
Spielmodus ever?
Ob die noch Leute
haben, die
Battle-Log überhaupt maintainen können?
Sieht nämlich nicht mehr so aus, oder?
Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich broken.
Doch!
Banana Republic!
Ja, den, den kenn ich.
Da hab ich auch ein paar Mal drauf gespielt.
Es gibt im Prinzip die zwei Server.
Damavand Peak, Only,
Rush, 64 Slot oder
Banana Republic.
So die zwei.
Computerfest.
Immerhin, immerhin noch mehr.
Und wo es tatsächlich gar nicht so gut ist,
wo es so wenige Server gibt,
kann man ja einfach vier draus machen.
Wo es tatsächlich gar nicht so wenige Server gibt,
ist Battlefield 4.
Man glaubt es kaum,
aber sogar Battlefield 4 wird noch ganz gut gespielt.
Ist blöd, wenn du
gebannt bist von einem der beiden aktiven
Server, ne?
Battlefield 3 ist mittlerweile so alt,
das ist zwar offen wie ein Scheunentor für Cheats
und alles, aber
ich glaube, es wird relativ selten
gecheatet, oder?
Weil das Spiel ist so alt und uninteressant
geworden, die Leute, die das nicht machen,
die das jetzt noch spielen, spielen es halt um des Spieles Willens
und nicht um zu cheaten.
Außerdem hast du wahrscheinlich auf diese,
ich mein, das ist ein einziger Server, da sind vielleicht
öfters auch ein paar Apartments am Start.
Wirst, wirst aber halt wahrscheinlich
auch relativ schnell gebannt, wenn du
einfach nur mal glückliche Runde hast.
Äh ja.
Ich würde mir echt wünschen, dass sie nochmal
ein Battlefield hinkriegen, mit dem gleichen
Hype wie Battlefield 3.
Das, ich mein, bei Battlefield 4
ging's schon runter, der ganze, der ganze
Hype drum.
So ein, so ein Hype wie um Battlefield 3.
Oder nicht nur ein Hype um Battlefield 3,
sondern, weil Hype hatten die Spiele am Anfang
initial immer mal ganz kurz, sondern
auch einen beständigen Hype, so wie
das Battlefield 3 hat. Das war einfach so
mega nice, dass du zwei Jahre lang
das Spiel durchgrinden konntest und jeder hatte Bock drauf.
Schade, dass sie es nicht noch,
noch, ähm, ja eigentlich,
eigentlich ja auch nur richtig ein Jahr,
bis das, bis der Content durch war.
Äh, eigentlich hätten sie Battlefield 4
noch ein Jahr später bringen sollen und das
Battlefield 3 noch versorgen, aber das,
das ist jetzt alles ungelegte Eier und
zehn Jahre her, who cares, ja.
Hast du mal Finals
gespielt? Nein, gespielt hab ich's nicht.
Ich hab's mir angeguckt,
ich hab's mir mal beim Lost, glaub ich,
angeguckt und ich hab's mir
bei nem
koreanischen Streamer angeguckt und,
also ich hab's mir ein bisschen angeguckt.
Ich muss sagen, rein vom Angucken hab ich's nicht so
hundertprozentig gecheckt, ob das, was es
jetzt genau ist. Es hat auf der einen Seite
ein bisschen Zerstörung,
wie man das so von DICE-Titeln
kennt.
Es hat aber Rumgesprünge mit auf Dächern
und es hat irgendwie
Extraction oder sowas.
Ich hab's nicht kapiert, ehrlich gesagt.
Den, den Spielmodus. Das war so
eine Mischung aus Extraction und
TDM. The Finals
mit Wiederbeleben.
Ganz merkwürdig. Ja, ich hab's,
ich hab's vom Angucken nicht gecheckt,
aber wahrscheinlich muss man das spielen, um's
zu checken. Ich hab, ich hab's nicht
kapiert. Ich, ich hab aber nicht wirklich
lang geguckt. War noch Elemente
von Rush? Okay.
Lass uns mal schauen, wie viele Leute
stellen sich das gerade auf Twitch.
Na, immerhin.
Ja, so.
Die, ah, die haben,
okay, die haben gerade Promotions.
Also wirklich krass beliebt ist es
jetzt auch nicht. Oh nein, nicht für mich empfohlen.
Viel zu wenig.
Also super krass beliebt
ist es jetzt auch nicht, aber immerhin.
Immerhin beliebter
als die meisten anderen Sachen.
Ich weiß nicht, ist es
free-to-play? Nicht, dass mich das stören
würde. Also interessiert mich einfach
nur. Weil ich glaube, die
meisten dieser Spiele, die, die, die
können sich fast nicht mehr erlauben
heutzutage nicht free-to-play zu sein.
Ja, mit Skins,
das dachte ich mir, das dachte ich mir.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Du kannst Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4
heute spielen. Max Settings, Ultra
Wide HD, äh,
volle Details,
240 FPS und läuft gut.
Und man muss sagen,
ich finde, die Spiele sehen heute immer noch,
verbrauchbar aus.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass du dir Battlefield 3
anguckst und dir denkst so,
boah, das ist das schönste Spiel aller Zeiten,
aber das sieht schon noch, also
ich finde Battlefield 3
hat eine, gerade auch aus der heutigen
Zeit betrachtet, hat eine
super,
ist ein super Kompromiss
aus Optik und Performance.
Gerade auf heutigen Rechnern
lutscht das einfach
so krass. 240 plus FPS
in 60,
so nach dem Motto.
Volle Details.
Und es sieht immer noch ganz okay aus.
Ja.
Das Beste an Battlefield 3,
so im Nachhinein, waren immer noch
die ganzen Voicecoms von den Soldaten.
Ich glaube,
würden die heute Battlefield 3 Voicecoms
machen, die Leute werden so
des Todes getriggert,
das könntest du heute, das könntest du heute
nimmer bringen. Die würden
alle ausrasten.
Guter Artstyle altert immer gut.
Es ist, da ist was
dran.
Für mich persönlich habe ich auch schon öfters
gesagt,
sehen Super Nintendo Spiele immer noch toll aus.
Und Super Nintendo Spiele
sind ja nun wirklich, wenn du das mit heutiger
Technik vergleichst, halt sehr minimalistisch.
Ja.
Aber das ist halt der Vorteil von
2D handgepixelt
versus 3D gerendert.
Und
ich muss halt sagen,
vielleicht liegt das auch daran, weil ich damit
aufgewachsen bin,
aber ich kann,
Wind Waker war, ja, Wind Waker
ist auch durch die ganze Cell-Shading-Geschichte
gut gealtert, obwohl es damals
gar nicht so gut angekommen ist, wegen dem
Cell-Shading-Look. Es gab ja vorher
diese, äh, quasi
Gamecube, äh, Zelda
Demo, die im realistischen Look
und alle haben halt erwartet, dass ein Spiel kommt,
was so aussieht, dann kam halt Wind Waker, dann haben viele Leute gesagt,
oh, was ist das? Aber Wind Waker ist gut
gealtert. Die HD-Variante von Wind Waker
auf der Wii U, die war auch
optisch sehr nice.
Aber bei mir ist es halt so, ich muss sagen,
ich kann 2D
Sprites und 2D
Pixel
Sachen irgendwie
mehr die Emotionen
abnehmen als 3D
Models. Schwer zu sagen,
warum. Vielleicht, weil man da
mehr Vorstellungskraft braucht,
anstatt, dass man es sieht.
Weiß nicht.
Naja, Chatge, was machen wir denn heute?
Ich hab, ich hab mir nichts, ich hab mir nichts
überlegt. Ich bin eigentlich nur
ongekommen, um euch zu sagen,
dass ich absolut keinen Bock hab.
Ne, besser gesagt, dass ich keinen hab,
keinen Bock, kek weh habe.
Ja? Morgen wieder
arbeiten zu gehen. Das ist, das ist
legit der einzige Grund, warum ich, warum ich
ongekommen bin. Jetzt hab ich euch das gesagt,
jetzt könnt ich eigentlich auch wieder aufgehen, das mach ich nicht.
Aber,
ich hab mir, ich hab mir nichts überlegt.
Ich wollte das einfach nur mal loswerden, dass ich
keinen Bock hab.
Das wollte ich mir nur angucken, richtig, ja.
Hab ich sogar schon offen.
Hast du dich schon mal, du meinst diesen
Videorecording oder Kamerarecording
Ding?
Beschäftigt ist zu viel
gesagt. Ich hab das mal in irgendeinem
Container gestartet und festgestellt, dass
das irgendwie nichts per WebRTC
überträgt. Und ich ja
hauptsächlich angucken will und nicht
aufnehmen will. Insofern
hat sich das dann für mich
erledigt.
Das ist auch so richtig.
Wer von euch muss morgen wieder arbeiten gehen?
Ich mein, ich geh mal davon aus, die meisten
von euch werden frei
gehabt haben, zumindest mal
heute, gestern,
vorgestern, also das Wochenende und
heute.
Nee, muss nicht. Ja.
Okay.
Das kenn ich, das kenn ich.
Falls Lernen auch
zählt.
Musst du dazu das Haus verlassen?
Zum Lernen?
Nee? Nee, dann zählt's nicht.
Am 16 wieder, sehr schön.
Nice.
Und
an alle, die morgen wieder arbeiten müssen, wie viel
Bock habt ihr, wieder arbeiten zu gehen?
Könntest du mal eine Stellenanzeige
reviewen und mir sagen, was du davon hältst?
Auf Indeed die Stellenanzeige von
First Colo GmbH
Datencenter in Frankfurt.
Ja, schick mir einen Link, kann ich mal angucken.
Wir haben doch sogar hier noch
irgendeine, die ich mir auch noch angucken sollte,
oder? Wolf EU.
Die hab ich jetzt schon so lange offen.
Die hab ich letztes Mal gesagt, guck ich mir an,
hab ich dann nie gemacht.
Urlaub.
Du freust
dich richtig.
Ich lese da raus, dass du dich
eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht freust, aber
sowas ist in geschriebener Form
immer schwer zu interpretieren.
Jaja, du hast den Link posten.
Doch, ist ernst gemeint. Alter.
Ich find's
wahrscheinlich morgen auch gar nicht so schlecht, wenn ich
dann erst mal da bin und es losgeht.
Aber so immer
vorbereitungstechnisch
so, also nee, also so
gedankentechnisch, dass es jetzt da wieder
losgeht, hab ich keinen Bock dran.
Du hast keinen Link
gepostet zur Stellenanzeige, oder?
Sondern woanders?
Okay.
Wir wollen nicht weiter mit Google.
Und wir haben deine, und wir haben deine
ID aus irgendwelchen
Gründen, weiß ich, ob das jetzt schlecht ist.
Welches? Ach, das hier.
Doch. Okay, Moment, ich muss das mal
kurz rüberkopieren.
Weil mich das
ziemlich
blendet.
Also wisst ihr, was das erste ist, was ich morgen mache?
Ich schließ mein Notebook an
und lass erstmal die ganzen Updates da dran laufen.
Da ist der halbe Tag schon mal rum.
Weil ich hatte den ganzen Dezember
nicht an, hab keine Updates bekommen.
Heißt im Endeffekt, morgen erstmal
halben Tag Notebook updaten.
Ist okay?
Die wollen das so?
Dann mach ich das.
Ähm.
Äh.
Stand da eben nicht noch mehr?
Sag mal, wie klein möchte man das bitte?
Alter, die ist ja,
Alter, die ist ja mies, diese Webseite.
What the fuck?
Wer macht denn solche Webseiten, Alter?
Was ist das?
Indeed.
So, was suchen die denn?
Die suchen einen Junior Systemadministrator.
Alles klar.
Zum Teil im Homeoffice. Wisst ihr, bei manchen Unternehmen,
also, ich kenn die nicht, ich sag's
einfach nur, bei manchen Unternehmen hab ich den Eindruck,
die machen da mittlerweile einfach nur
das Häkchen, dass die Leute überhaupt
reingucken und am Ende steht dann
sowas wie, nur nach Absprache mit
dem Vorgesetzten und dann will's der
Vorgesetzte nicht.
Bereitschaftsdienst, ja.
Ist schon, ist schon okay.
Okay.
First Kolo
ist ein Betreiber von
Okay, das lesen wir uns nicht durch.
Das ist wieder die übliche Selbstbeweihräucherung,
die vor jeder Stellenanzeige kommt.
Ich kenn die, mir kommt der Name bekannt vor.
Ich hab das schon mal gehört.
First Kolo.
Das kenn ich.
Haben die, Moment, lasst uns mal kurz
auf den ihrer Webseite gucken.
An welchen Standorten die in Frankfurt
sind. Standorte.
Hanauer Landstraße, hab ich das grad schon da was
gesehen. Ja.
Das ist durchaus möglich, dass ich
die da schon...
Gut, das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Accelerated.
Das sagt mir auch irgendwas.
Aber Hanauer Landstraße
ist durchaus möglich. Da ist ja der DZX dann auch
nicht weit. Aber die hab ich schon mal
gehört. Gesehen will ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Bin ich mir nicht sicher, aber gehört auf jeden Fall
schon. Ist aber auch
durchaus möglich, dass ich da irgendwann schon mal drinne war.
Ich bin mir
echt nicht sicher.
Also Hanauer Landstraße war ich schon an einigen.
In der Kleierstraße war ich auch schon in einigen.
In...
Wie hieß das andere?
Das war jetzt zumindest die einzigen zwei, die mir da so
aus dem Kopf einfallen. Und da hast du ja auch, wo du
hinspuckst.
Rechenzentrumsanbieter.
Also gehört hab ich den Namen auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Schon drinne war weiß ich net.
Kann aber sein.
Also. Aufgaben.
Als Teil von Managed
Service...
Als Teil von... Soll das nicht
als Teil von Managed Services heißen?
Ach nee.
Ach nee. Managed Service. Das Team heißt
Managed Service. Achso.
Als Teil...
Als Teil von Managed Service bist du
mit dem Tagesgeschäft betraut und kümmerst
dich um die Konzipierung und Bereitstellung der Kundeninfraschung.
Ja gut.
Du liebst abwechslungsreiches
Arbeiten und suchst die Herausforderung
in unterschiedlichen Bereichen.
Bei uns
konzeptionierst,
administrierst und verantwortest du eigene
Serverlandschaften und Kundeninfrastrukturen.
Okay.
Du bist wissbegierig und
aufgeschlossen. Unsere Kollegen führen dich an
neue Technologien heran.
Insidere Fachabteilung. Okay.
Das ist beides unglaublich nicht zu handfinden.
Es ist so.
Wie sehr möchtest du umschreiben, was
du wirklich machst?
Du scheuerst... Moment.
Du scheust dich nicht.
Scheuern vielleicht auch.
Weil bei Kundengesprächen scheuer ich
mich davor. Du scheuerst
dich nicht vor Kundengesprächen.
Du unterstützt deine Kollegen
bei Kundenbetreuung und stehst ihnen
bei Rückfragen und
der Angebotsgestaltung zur Seite.
Okay.
Also ich scheue mich vor
Kundengesprächen. Also wenn das
Endkunden sind.
Was wahrscheinlich ist. Da hätte ich überhaupt
keinen Bock drauf. Endkundengespräch ist immer ganz
abartig.
Musst dich glücklicherweise nie großartig machen.
Du bist neugierig. Wir betreiben mehrere
Virtualisierungsplattformen.
Proxmox, Kubernetes und VMware.
Auch ein OpenStack und
ZEV mit einigen IP...
Das ist okay. Das ist eine wilde Mischung.
VMware, Proxmox, Kubernetes
und OpenStack.
Wir machen einfach mal alles.
ZEV ist ja noch was anderes.
ZEV als Distributed Storage.
Wie spricht man
einen Rechtschreibfehler in einer Stellenanzeige an?
Gar nicht.
Ja, genau das würde ich auch sagen. Gar nicht.
Das ist so
ein typischer Fall von...
Wie soll ich sagen? Also...
Es juckt einen
vielleicht, da mal klug zu scheißen, aber
auch wenn man sich jetzt
denken könnte, sie
müssten sich darüber freuen, auf Fehler hingewiesen
zu werden, ist die Chance, dass
sie sich nicht darüber freuen, höher.
Deswegen, ich würde
einfach gar nichts dazu sagen.
So, Anforderungen. Was wollen sie haben?
Sie suchen, wohlgemerkt, sie suchen einen Junior.
Also mal gucken, ob das passt.
Du bringst erste Erfahrung in der
Linux-Administration mit. Du solltest
nicht auf eine Linux-Distribution
limitiert sein.
Wir setzen vorwiegend Debian
und Jubantu
basierte Systeme ein.
Oh, nice.
Debian ist schon mal
richtige Wahl.
Super.
Kann man sich streiten, aber gerade im Cloud
und im Enterprise-Sektor, wenn es
nicht Red Hat ist, dann ist es
halt nun mal öfters Ubuntu.
Manche Verrückte machen auch
Suse, aber wer macht denn sowas?
Du bist dir unsicher, ob du
ausreichend Erfahrung hast. Bewirb dich
und film es gemeinsam heraus. Okay.
Dann wirst du dann gefragt, wie kommst du aus Wim raus?
Oder sowas.
Du hast Interesse, dich in neue Technologien selbstständig
und unter Einladung einzuarbeiten.
Wir stellen Infrastrukturen
von einfachen Web-Servern und Datenbank-Servern
über redundante Web-Stacks
bis hin zu kompletten und mehrfach
redundanten Virtualisierungsumgebungen für unsere Kunden zur Verfügung.
Du bist kommunikationsstark.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich?
Was fällt euch noch an?
Was fällt euch noch ein?
Doppelpunkt Q? Doppelpunkt WQ?
Richtig, da warte ich
immer drauf. Da warte ich, weil nur die echten
Hackermans wissen, dass man Wim mit Shift-ZZ
beenden kann.
Auch Scrap-Wim, Kill-Wim,
P-Kill-Wim, das zählt nicht.
Ich sag doch, nur echten
Hackermans wissen, dass das geht.
Sehr gut.
Doppelpunkt X geht im Zweifelsfall
auch noch, wenn ihr schreiben wollt.
Weil Doppelpunkt X und WQ das gleiche ist.
Was darf man sich darunter vorstellen?
Du bist kommunikationsstark.
Das ist eine Redewendung,
die sehe ich total oft, aber was konkret
wollen die damit eigentlich sagen?
Ich habe wieder den Eindruck, dass
das ist so eine coole Redewendung,
die da reingeschrieben wird,
aber die haben sich selbst gar keine
genauen Gedanken darüber gemacht,
was die eigentlich wollen.
Rumgeschreiende, das meinen sie wahrscheinlich
eher nicht, aber das könnte man da auch
reininterpretieren.
Die meinen damit wahrscheinlich,
dass du quasi klar und sicher
mit anderen Leuten kommunizieren kannst,
was jetzt Sache ist.
Aber es ist echt,
ich kann mir da immer nichts unter
denken, dass du dich gut ausdrücken kannst
in den Meetings oder mit Kunden vernünftig
reden kannst. Ja, siehste,
Blue Sky, genau das ist das,
was ich mir darunter vorstellen würde,
umschrieben, aber immer sehr
schwierig, weil das Interpretation...
Kann man das nicht irgendwie so
reinschreiben? Ich meine vielleicht nicht so,
wie es jetzt direkt bei dir aus der Tastatur
gerade geflossen ist, aber
in irgendeiner Art und Weise, so dass man
das da ohne viel
Interpretation rauslesen kann.
Okay, nice, also...
Gute Englischkenntnisse
sind wünschenswert. Easy.
Du arbeitest
sorgfältig und bist mit...
und bist dir der
Verantwortung für den Infrastruktur unserer Kunden bewusst.
Du bist ein Teamplayer. Dein Team kann sich auf
deine Zuverlässigkeit verlassen. Du unterstützt
das Team im Rahmen der extra vergüteten
Rufbereitschaft. Oh ja!
Rufbereitschaft muss ich glaube ich auch
einmal am Wochenende diesen Monat
wieder machen. Da gibt's wieder...
Leute, das ist so... das ist so
lustig, ne? Ihr müsst euch
jetzt mal die Ohren zuhalten, weil das
teilweise schon echt...
Es grenzt fast
schon an Gelddruckmaschine
für wenig bis nichts arbeiten
viel Geld bekommen.
Bei uns bekommst du knapp, knapp,
es ist ein bisschen weniger, es kommt ein bisschen drauf an,
von wann bis wann, aber aufgerundet
knapp 1000 Euro
für Rufbereitschaft
am Wochenende. Das ist so krass, Alter!
Da musst du natürlich noch Steuern drauf bezahlen.
Wir reden jetzt nicht, dass du das überwiesen
kriegst.
Es ist so heftig.
Rufbereitschaft...
Jaja, also Moment, mehr als das
ganze Wochenende. Rufbereitschaft
ist Freitag 17 Uhr
bis Montags
8 Uhr.
Dann kriegst du ungefähr 1000 Euro.
Doch, ich bezahl Steuern
drauf, dann krieg ich Rentenpunkte.
Mir wäre es aber
lieber, das wäre steuerfrei.
24,7 Euro.
Sicher auch
Abgaben? Nein, nicht sicher.
Aber wie kontaktieren die dich,
wenn du pennst?
Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Erste Eskalationsstufe ist
Message.
Ich sag jetzt nicht, über welchen Kanal die reinkommen.
Message aufs Handy.
Da musst du halt dein Handy laut lassen nachts.
Dann macht es dann blim,
blim oder was auch immer du für
SMS eingestellt hast.
Als Handy laut hast.
Erste Eskalationsstufe ist...
Ich nenn's mal SMS.
Zweite Eskalationsstufe ist
dich ruft irgendeiner an.
Ich bekomm das mit.
Bekomm das mit.
Zweite Eskalationsstufe ist, du wirst angerufen.
Sollte irgendwas sein
und sogar schon die Leute,
die für die eigentliche Anwendung zuständig sind,
das mitbekommen
haben, dann rufen die dich auch an.
Gab es das schon mal
dass du nachts rein musstest? Nein.
Rein nicht, aber einloggen nachts.
Das gab's schon.
Ja.
Besonders geil, wenn man neu ist und die ganzen Systeme
nicht kennt.
Und das Witzige bei uns ist halt,
die Leute, die sich
für die Systeme zuständig sind,
die kennen die. Die anderen kennen sie eigentlich
alle mehr oder weniger nicht sonderlich gut.
Und ich kenn die meisten halt gar nicht richtig.
Außer meine.
Und
es ist eh immer
Planlosigkeit angesagt, wenn da was kommt
an SMS.
Ich hab auch schon nachts
Nachrichten gekriegt.
Da sind dann so Meldungen
drin wie
Check MK empfängt keine Daten mehr.
Und da denk ich mir, what the fuck, Alter.
Was juckt's mich? Aber oftmals deutet das halt auf was hin,
dass irgendwas Größeres kaputt ist.
Muss man nach dem Anruf instant
bzw. nach der Nachricht instant verfügbar sein
oder hat man Zeit zum Beispiel nach Hause zu fahren?
Umso schneller,
umso besser. Aber du hast ne gewisse Zeit.
Also du musst nicht instant verfügbar sein.
Instant gibt's ja eh nicht.
5 Minuten wäre für mich instant.
Es ist mehr als 5 Minuten.
Also du hast durchaus Zeit,
wenn du grade
beim
EDK bist und noch
20 Minuten heimlaufen musst.
Abends oder so.
Dann ist das im Rahmen. Da geht das.
Kein Problem.
Aber lasst uns doch grad mal die Stellenanzeige fertig machen.
Nicht die hier, die andere.
Du bist ein Teamplayer.
Dein Team kann sich auf deine Zuverlässigkeit verlassen.
Du unterstützt das Team.
Okay, das hatten wir gerade schon.
Deine Vorteile.
Flexiblen sind die flexiblen Arbeitszeiten.
Gestalte deine Arbeit
Tag nach Tag.
Das liest sich immer gut.
Es ist
komplett Interpretationssache,
wie es dann gelebt wird.
Kontinuierliche
Weiterbildung.
Hybrides Arbeiten.
Genieße die Freiheit, sowohl im Büro als auch remote
zur Arbeit maximale Flexibilität zu erleben.
Liest sich auch gut.
Wie es dann praktisch aussieht,
weiß man halt nicht.
Respekt und Wertschätzung.
Bei uns steht nicht nur die Arbeit
im Mittelpunkt,
sondern auch der Mensch.
Wenn die jetzt was anfangen
von Familie zu erzählen.
Wir sind stolz darauf, eine Kultur des Respekts
und der Wertschätzung zu fördern.
Okay, das ist alles für die hohle Hand,
wie es wichtig ist, wie es intern auch wirklich gelebt wird.
Oder gemacht wird.
Die schreiben einfach viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Mitarbeiter Events.
Tauche in unsere Teamkultur ein.
Sei es bei Teambuilding,
Aktivitäten, Firmenausflügen
und gemeinsamen Feierlichkeiten.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten.
Gesundheitsförderung.
Wir legen Wert auf, okay, gut.
Sportangebote, Fitnesskurse,
leckeres Mittagessen.
Genieße zweimal pro Woche
köstliche Mahlzeiten, während du dich mit deinen Kollegen austauschst.
Okay.
Kann ich die auch genießen, ohne mich auszutauschen dabei?
Einfach nur fressen
und wieder arbeiten gehen?
Oder ist das so ein Event,
wo du nur hingehen kannst, wenn du auch
richtig krass socializest dabei?
Vielfältige Verfügungsmöglichkeiten.
Genieße eine riesige Auswahl an Getränken,
Snacks, darunter Müsli von MyMüsli.
Schon nie gehört.
Was ist MyMüsli?
Mein persönliches Lieblingsmüsli, aha.
Ich esse nur Müsli von
Seitenbacher.
Nee, ich esse gar kein Müsli.
Leckere Joghurts und vieles mehr.
Ah ja.
So, Chatgear, wer war das, der das geschickt hat eben?
Ja.
Marc.
Ich finde die Stellanzeige geht in Ordnung.
Die ist zwar nichts herausragendes
jetzt, wo man sagen wird,
boah, da waren sie aber super krass kreativ.
Oder, boah, das habe ich aber noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist so im Bereich,
wo ich mir denke,
ja, der Laden könnte durchaus was taugen.
Wissen anhand der Stellanzeige kann man es nicht.
Ich würde aber nicht sagen,
es sieht offensichtlich kacke aus.
Es sieht halt sehr 0815 aus.
Finde ich.
Der Laden kann super sein.
Kann auch nichts taugen.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Wir können es ja nur anhand der Stellanzeige hier bewerten.
Genauso wie die Unternehmen das immer nur
bei uns anhand der Bewerbung bewerten können.
Also,
ziemlich Standard, würde ich sagen.
Chat, was denkt ihr?
Also, wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach
recht 0815.
Ja, 0815 HR-Abteilung.
Genauso liest sich auch.
Ja, ziemlich Standard.
Das Müsli
von Seitenbacher, genau.
Teambuilding.
Na, ich war im Dezember,
im letzten
Oktober war das.
Letzte Oktobertage.
War ich ja auch auf dem Teambuilding-Workshop.
Der ging halbwegs klar.
Ich hab da kein Geheimnis drum gemacht,
dass ich eigentlich keinen Bock hab, aber
der ging schon irgendwie halbwegs klar.
Zwischenzeitlich las es sich
ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen wie
Ergänzt durch ChatGPT.
Nicht geschrieben komplett durch ChatGPT,
aber es las sich auf jeden Fall
Ergänzt durch ChatGPT.
Das trifft's, das fasst's eigentlich grad zuzuhaben.
Sieht halt aus wie ein Job.
Ja.
Okay, haben wir dicht.
Hm.
Hab ich eigentlich jetzt schon Package-Updates hier gemacht?
Ja, gell, Freund?
Naja, hab ich.
Okay.
Wollen uns da noch irgendwas angucken?
Lass uns doch jetzt grade, dass wir's noch hinkriegen.
ChatGPT, ist derjenige da, der diese Stellenanzeige gepostet hat?
Irgendjemand wollte, dass wir uns das hier angucken?
Ich hab's seit drei Wochen oder so
nicht geschafft.
Wahrscheinlich schon mittlerweile längst die Bewerbung raus
oder abgelehnt oder Job schon bekommen
oder was auch immer.
Wir können uns aber nochmal schnell angucken.
Just für den Fall der Fälle.
Also, wen haben wir denn hier?
Wolf.eu
Deine Tätigkeit, was suchen sie denn?
Sie suchen einen IT-Administrator.
Administration, Erweiterung, Wartung von zentralen
wie dezentralen Betrieben im Server-
und Netzwerksystem.
Okay, das ist super allgemein.
Das ist wirklich, also
mehr allgemein beschreiben kann man
die Tätigkeit eigentlich kaum.
Konzeptionierung,
Konfiguration und Betrieb von IT-Infrastruktur
mit Fokus auf...
Da wäre ich jetzt schon raus an der Stelle.
Ich such zwar nix, aber ich wäre schon
an der Stelle raus.
Keck Microsoft, Alter.
Analyse und Lösung
von Applikations-
Betriebssystem-Datenbank-Problem.
Okay, deswegen ist es ein bisschen minimal
konkreter, kann aber auch immer noch alles sein,
weil alles ist irgendwie ein Applikations-
Betriebssystem- oder Datenbank-Problem.
Mitwirkung bei Projekten, Definition des Zielsystems
Was?
Mitwirkung bei Projekten.
So weit verstehe ich noch.
Was ist Definition des Zielsystems?
Was meinen die
damit, Chat?
Seid mal kreativ, was könnte damit gemeint sein?
Die meinen damit bestimmt nicht, verwenden wir Red Hat
oder Ubuntu oder Debian.
Also, wisst's auch nicht.
Mitwirkung und Steuerung
der Umsetzung an verschiedenen Standorten.
Also Mitwirkung, ja, ob Steuerung
jetzt in der Aufgabenbereich von einem
Admin gefällt, kann man sich echt drüber
streiten.
Auf welcher Kiste das
laufen soll?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das
damit gemeint ist.
Zusammenarbeit mit internen Teams.
Admin-Initiation, Wartung, Überwachung,
Backup, Verwaltung der
Benutzeridentität, Zugriff auf IT-Systeme,
alles klar.
Behebungsabläufe, okay, auch alles klar.
Abgeschlossen, was wollen sie haben?
Übliche Geschichte, Ausbildung oder
Studium oder bla bla.
Mehrjährige Berufserfahrung im Bereich
IT-Support, MonkaS,
oder IT-Systemintegration.
Lösungsorientierte, analytische Arbeitsweise,
vertiefte Kenntnisse, eine oder mehrere folgende
Server-Client-Computing.
Das ist auch sehr
weit gefasst.
Virtualisierung.
Also da hat auf jeden Fall
die Abteilung, die das Ding geschrieben hat,
wieder nicht genau
verstanden oder wusste,
was die eigentlich wollen, oder?
Oder mehreren der folgenden Punkte
bringst du bereits eine große Erfahrungsschatz mit.
Windows Server, VMware, Commvault,
kenne ich nicht, VDI.
Also sagt mir wenigstens was, was es ist.
Commvault habe ich noch nie gehört, VMware klar,
habe ich aber auch keine große Erfahrung mit.
Windows Server will ich gar keine Erfahrung mit haben.
Was ist Commvault?
Data Protection against
Cyberthreats. Excellent.
Okay, die kommen aus den USA.
Dann ist alles Cyberthreat,
was wahrscheinlich nicht die NSA ist.
Erfahrung im Bereich Server-Virtualisierung.
Okay, die wollen es aber echt wissen
mit Server-Virtualisierung, oder?
Vertiefte Kenntnisse im Bereich
Virtualisierung, VMware.
Erfahrung im Bereich
Virtualisierung.
Leute, glaubt ihr,
die wollen jemanden, der schon mal was virtualisiert hat?
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Könnte sein.
Vielleicht.
Hohes Maß an Teamfähigkeit, Flexibilität.
Am Ende nutzen sie Hyper-V.
Aber ich steh zumindest
VMware drin.
Selbstständigkeit, Überzeugungskraft und
Durchsetzungsformen sowie
interkulturelle Kompetenz.
Was?
Da kann ich mir zum Beispiel schon mal gar nichts drunter
vorstellen.
Was ist interkulturelle Kompetenz?
Ah, ich weiß es. Die haben was
outgesourced nach Indien.
Die haben 100% was outgesourced nach Indien
oder Rumänien oder Dubai
oder wo auch immer man was hin outsourced.
Und das meinen die bestimmt.
Dass du da auch
mit denen klar kommst.
Sehr gute deutsche und englische Kenntnisse.
Ok.
Microsoft Gold Support.
Großer fachlicher Freiraum.
Ja.
Liest sich auch sehr 0815.
Also wer auch immer das gepostet hat,
kann man jetzt nicht wirklich
daran ableiten, ob die besonders gut
oder besonders schlecht sind.
Ist sehr 0815 Standard Zeug.
Das glaub ich
in dem Fall nicht.
Das könnte man so aus dem Bauchgefühl
mäßig da vielleicht rein interpretieren.
Aber wenn man ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt,
das glaub ich nicht, dass sowas
selbst
wenn das der Fall wäre, irgendwie
den Weg in die Stellanzeige finden würde.
Realistischer ist, sie haben
einiges outgesourced
und du musst klar kommen mit,
wenn du mit Leuten aus Indien telefonierst,
dass die vielleicht ein bisschen anders ticken.
Vielleicht gab es ja da in der Vergangenheit schon öfters Probleme mit.
In der Zusammenarbeit mit dem outgesourcten
Kram nach Indien, was ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann.
Also ich gehe
eher davon aus,
dass das was ist, weil sie irgendwas
outgesourct haben.
Oder was heißt outgesourct? Muss ja nicht mal outgesourct sein.
Kann ja auch sein,
dass das tatsächlich zum Laden gehört.
Aber halt hauptsächlich
woanders.
Old on, old on.
Oder eingesourct, ja.
Ich hab jetzt schon gehört, dass man im
ManagerSpeak
nicht mehr outgesourct sagt,
sondern, und auch nicht
also es gab mal einen Trend, da hat man
outgesourct gesagt.
Dann hat man gesagt
offshore oder sowas
und mittlerweile sagt man
nearshoring.
Das ist ein anderes Wort für
es ist halt EU-Ausland,
wo man das outgesourct hat.
Man hat es aber nicht outgesourct, sondern
man hat es
nearshoring.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das überhaupt
richtig Sätze bilden soll damit.
Am ManagerSpeak
ändert sich ja auch immer ein bisschen.
Nearshoring.
Funktioniert es ja auch
zum größten Teil nicht.
Deswegen ist diese ganze Outsourcing-Geschichte
gar nicht
mehr so im Trend.
Mich würde interessieren, wie breit du das
Tätigkeitsspektrum eines IT-Admins siehst,
also für wie viel
ein Admin zuständig sein soll.
Das Spektrum ist enorm breit,
weil an vielen Stellen Admin draufsteht
und die überhaupt keine Admin sind.
So nach dem Motto, ja,
die, keine Ahnung,
die Abmachung mit dem Betriebsrat
sieht halt vor, dass es nur Admin-Stellen
gibt in dem und dem Bereich, aber eigentlich
brauchen wir gar keine Admins, sondern
Cloud-Infrastruktur-Leute, DevOps-Leute
und Admins und
hast du nicht gesehen, die haben halt alle dann den Titel Admin.
Hab ich auch schon gesehen und
insofern enorm breit.
Weil es nicht zwangsläufig
ein Administrator sein muss, nur weil Administrator
dransteht.
Viel wichtiger ist, was du konkret da für
Tätigkeitsfelder definiert hast.
Alles Cloud. Ja, und Leute,
denkt dran, nicht Cloud-Anbieter
oder gar Cloud-Provider, sondern
Hyperscaler. Mich würde es nicht
wundern, wenn es Unternehmen gibt,
wo Admins Full-Stack-Entwickler
sind oder beziehungsweise
Full-Stack-Entwickler auf ihrer
in ihrer Personalakte
ein Admin drinstehen haben.
Nein, war ich nicht.
Ich wollte mir, ich hab mir ein paar
Talks gespeichert, ich mir angucken
wollte,
aber hab ich noch nicht einen reingeschaut.
Bisher.
Einer hatte einen Talk drüber über
Sicherheitslücken bei...
Ach, da hat mich die Überschrift schon angesprochen.
Ich hab's vergessen.
Sicherheitslücken bei...
Irgendwas, wo ich mir gedacht hab.
In alten Games.
In alten Multiplayer-Games.
So nach dem Motto Remote Code Execution
mit alten Multiplayer-Games.
Das wollte ich mir angucken.
Hab ich letztens in den YouTube-Empfehlungen gehabt.
Ich glaub, das
wurde dort
gepräsentiert.
Wie in CS.
Wieso hatte CS da Probleme
in der Richtung?
Und CS ist ja wirklich...
Hatte CS?
Inwiefern? Das hab ich gar nicht
mitbekommen.
CS2 has found a bug
that can be used to steal
personal data.
Ja, geil.
Nicht sanitized HTML im
Vault-Kick-Fenster.
Es sind aber auch immer die Basics,
die nicht hinhauen, oder?
Oh, Mann.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass solche offensichtlichen
Dinger... Leute, und soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Weil wir es gerade letztens davon hatten.
Mit Rust wäre das auch passiert.
Da kann Rust
überhaupt nichts dran ändern.
Oh, guck mal, mein Kanal.
Schade, morgen in meine neue Stelle als
Software-Developer rein. Plus 20 mehr Gehalt.
Excellent. Und hast du Bock, morgen
anzufangen? Weil
die Sache bei mir ist, ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock,
wieder arbeiten zu müssen, morgen.
Du bist gehypt. Okay.
Ja, also, ich muss sagen, als ich im April
angefangen hab, war ich so...
Die ersten
Wochen auch gehypt.
Weil es halt einfach was Neues war.
Mittlerweile hab ich mich schon wieder ganz gut dran gewöhnt.
Der Hype ist abgeklungen.
Ja.
Ja, wenig.
Wir haben ein paar...
Ich hab vorhin im Chat gefragt,
und da haben ein paar Leute gesagt,
die freuen sich tatsächlich richtig drauf, morgen.
Konnte ich nicht nachvollziehen,
aber ich mein, jeder, worauf er Bock hat, ja.
100% Remote
bin immer noch gehypt. Ja, kann man auch.
100% Remote ist
POG.
Ich hoffe, die bezahlen das auch richtig gut,
weil dann wäre es doppelt POG.
Das Problem hab ich in der Tat nicht.
Das ist jetzt nur,
weil ich quasi einen Monat
daheim gesessen hab und Kreisel-Crime
gemacht hab, da ich keinen Bock hab.
Wie gesagt, ich mach ja
auch ne 4-Tage-Woche und ich hab überhaupt keine Probleme mehr.
Montags hab ich ja übrigens frei.
Dienstags
dann wieder anzufangen. Überhaupt nicht.
Ich kann übrigens nach wie vor
jedem nur wärmstens
empfehlen, sich das zu überlegen.
Gerade für alle, die in der IT arbeiten
und eben mehr als genug Kohle verdienen.
Ich kann das euch allen wärmstens nur empfehlen.
Überlegt euch mal, ob 4-Tage-Woche
nicht was für euch ist.
Nein, nicht BDO.
Eine 2-Tage-Woche wär POG-Champ.
Leute, wisst ihr,
was ich mir letztens überlegt hab?
Es gibt ja immer mehr Diskussionen darüber,
ob jetzt nicht
die 4-Tage-Woche eingeführt werden soll.
Also, ich persönlich
geh davon aus, dass es kein Unternehmen
freiwillig macht, weil es sich wieder
irgendwie nicht traut. Gerade in Deutschland so moderne
Sachen, das wird nix.
Aber wenn die ne 4-Tage-Woche einführen
und sollten die bei mir dort, wo ich arbeite,
jemals eine 4-Tage-Woche
für alle einführen, wohlgemerkt
bei gleichbleibender Bezahlung, das ist ja das,
was hier teilweise diskutiert wird,
dann werde ich zur 3-Tage-Woche
wechseln. Wenn es sich natürlich
um 4-Tage-Woche handelt,
die
2 Stunden mehr am Tag bedeuten,
da hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Aber wenn das wirklich kommt bei uns,
dann würde ich,
dann habe ich 2 Sachen zur Auswahl.
Entweder
ich bekomme einfach
20% mehr Geld,
weil ja alle von 5 Tagen auf 4 Tage
war gleich eine Bezahlung, oder
ich gehe einfach runter auf 3 Tage
und
dann, das wäre mir ja fast noch
lieber, keck weight.
Am besten, Leute, ich bin
nächstes Jahr 40, am besten ich gehe
gleich in Altersteilzeit, oder was meint ihr?
Soll ich in Altersteilzeit
gehen schon?
Ich glaube mit 39, knapp 40
kann man sich das schon mal überlegen.
Wird Zeit, denke ich auch.
0 Tage und trotzdem bezahlt,
ja, das wird natürlich jeder nehmen.
Mein ETF geht richtig
big stonks.
Seit
2 Monaten oder so.
Lass mich gerade mal kurz gucken.
Es wurde jetzt zwar nicht gehandelt die letzten Tage,
aber ich habe jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt,
lasst mal kurz schauen.
Loggen Sie sich ein, Alter, Scalable geht mir auf den Sack.
Ja, ich logge mich ein, ist gut.
Boah.
Die Stonks gehen echt gut, gut rauf.
Ja.
Ich würde es ohne Probleme machen, 100% Remote.
Ich finde es aber auch
in Ordnung, wenn die sagen 100% Remote wollen
sie nicht, der nächste Standort ist
noch nicht so weit weg, ein Tag die Woche, so wie es
bei mir aktuell ist, habe ich auch keine Probleme mit.
Hätte ich auch beim letzten Laden keine Probleme
gehabt, hätten die da nicht drauf bestanden,
so nach dem Motto, alle wieder in die Firma
und so Zeug, dann
hätte ich es noch nicht, wäre ich da
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht weg beim alten Laden.
Paysafe?
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde keine random
Ausweisfotos und sonstige
Sachen schicken.
Das wollten auch schon einige
Hosting-Anbieter von mir, nachdem ich mich
registriert habe, unter anderem
auch,
ich weiß nicht wer es war,
netcup war es glaube ich,
da habe ich eine Werbung gesehen
von denen auf Twitter und habe darauf geantwortet,
ich würde es ja gerne bei euch wieder ausprobieren, aber
muss ich immer noch meinen Ausweis einscannen?
Wie wäre es denn mit so etwas wie Postident?
Und dann meinten sie, nein, leider ist es nicht mit
Postident möglich und Ausweis einscannen.
Gut, dann halt
nichts für mich.
Wie wichtig ist heutzutage ein
Master im Informatikbereich deiner Meinung nach?
Lohnt sich das? Das kann man
pauschal nicht sagen.
Durchschnittsgehalt technisch
lohnt sich das sicherlich, was jetzt aber
nicht im Einzelfall
das wusstest du nicht,
dann
sie haben selbst geschrieben auf Twitter, dass
das noch teilweise der Fall ist.
Also,
es ist nicht so, als hätte ich mir das ausgedacht.
Also, Glück gehabt.
Also, durchschnittsgehalt technisch, lohnt
sich das? Ob sich jetzt im Einzelfall
bei dir lohnt?
Also, ich meine, du kannst auch fette Kohle
verdienen, ohne dass du eine Master in Informatik hast.
Kommt ein bisschen darauf an,
was du machen willst, in welchem Bereich.
Also, wenn du zu irgendwelchen Ämtern willst,
die stehen halt unglaublich auf Studium.
Ich kann es
schlecht aus persönlicher Erfahrung
beantworten, weil ich nicht studiert habe.
Aber ich denke, ich verdiene für
uns Studierende auch nicht übel Kohle.
Also,
das kann ich dir nicht beantworten.
Also, ich würde sagen, es ist
heute so wenig wie möglich, äh,
so wenig
nötig, wie
jemals. Also, es war noch
niemals so wenig nötig, wie
jetzt. So, das wollte ich sagen.
Schaden tut's
nicht, ja,
wenn du das machen willst.
Aber nötig ist es nicht.
Wichtig ist, dass du was kannst.
Was gesucht wird.
Obol.
Ja gut, 4 Tage Woche,
bei mir ist ja auch nicht nach gleicher Bezahlung,
sondern halt, ich krieg einen Tag weniger
Geld, aber ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ist immer noch genug Kohle.
Meinst du, dass die überhaupt mit 3 Tagen mitziehen?
Ja, sehr wahrscheinlich.
Weil wir haben einen Betriebsrat und wir haben
sogar Regelungen für Teilzeitarbeit und ja,
das geht.
Ich könnte auch theoretisch auf ganz auf
100% reduzieren.
Dann müsste ich nur für 2,5 Tage arbeiten.
Vielleicht sollte ich das echt machen,
Leute.
Kohle gibt's genug.
Und wenn ich ein bisschen
mehr mache, was Twitch und YouTube angeht,
gibt's da auch noch ganz brauchbar was.
Und dann mehr Kreiselgrind.
Endlich mehr Zeit für MMO-Kreiselgrind,
meinst du?
Ne, ne, das heißt nicht, dass es 50%
mehr Max gibt. Das heißt, ich hab mehr Zeit,
äh, den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner zu sitzen und
Sachen zu spielen. Aber nicht, dass ich unbedingt mehr streame
oder YouTube-Videos mache. Ihr kennt mich.
Wenn ich mir sowas vornehme, wird's nie was.
Was, Bitcoin geht auch ab?
Lass mal kurz gucken. Bitcoin-Kurs.
Oh.
Naja.
Oh ja, doch, doch.
Oh, doch.
Ist das allzeit hoch? So geil hat's schon
über 40.000 gewesen.
Sorry for Bash, danke für den Sub.
Gehörig schrauf hier.
Ne, 80.000
waren allzeit hoch oder so.
60? Ne, 80.000.
Nice.
Ja.
Wie immer, ne,
nachher ist man schlauer und
denkt sich, na, hätte ich mir hier mal was geholt. Aber
ist halt falsch gedacht.
Du kannst halt nicht wissen.
Hab mal eine Frage.
Jeff Bezos muss ins Weltall hier.
Der Hype-Train ist am Start.
Du hast nur wenig Zeit, Leute. Gleich ist's
vorbei.
Es ist immer der gleiche. Es ist genauso wie jetzt
Winterschlussverkauf und sowas.
Letztens hab ich sogar noch gehört,
letztens Radio-Werbung. Ja, manchmal
geb ich mir sowas noch.
Es gibt jetzt einen Winterschlussverkauf
Pre-Sale.
Das ist quasi der Winterschlussverkauf,
der früher anfängt, aber der angeblich
schon Pre-Schlussverkauf.
Das ist
einfach nur noch bescheuert mittlerweile.
Ich mein, nach
Black Friday,
Black Friday Week,
Cyber Monday,
Cyber Week,
Christmas Sale,
New Year's Sale wird es...
Alter, es ist ja irgendwann auch mal gut.
Wir glauben
euch nicht, dass ihr uns was schenkt von
heute auf morgen.
Wobei, es scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Was wollte ich? Ach ja, hier.
Hab mal eine Frage. Ich bin...
Ich überlege eine Ausbildung zum Physi zu machen
nach dem Abitur.
Wollte aber auch gerne dual studieren.
Ich hatte schon mal eine mehrere Physis,
die erst nach der Ausbildung noch mal
studieren gegangen sind. Was mache ich?
Was lohnt sich überhaupt? Also ganz ehrlich,
Physi-Ausbildung ist halt von der Schule her
easy as fuck.
Da musst du dir überhaupt keine Gedanken machen.
Jeder kann easy die Physi-Ausbildung
schaffen.
Und danach hast du zumindest ein bisschen praktische
Erfahrung. Beim dualen Studieren
theoretisch auch, aber
Studieren ist halt deutlich
fordernder als
der theoretische Teil der Ausbildung.
Also wenn du dich anstrengen willst,
wenn du dich reinhängen willst,
dann studiere.
Man kommt heute aber auch ohne Probleme mit
einer Physi-Ausbildung
klar, wenn man denn Ahnung
hat von dem, was man macht.
Und ja, ich kenne auch einige, die nach
der Physi-Ausbildung studiert haben.
Vielleicht weiß man dann besser,
was man vorhat. Das kann ich dir
nicht beantworten. Ich kenne ehrlich gesagt
auch aus persönlicher Erfahrung die Vor- und Nachteile
nicht. Und ich habe mich mit dualem
Studium auch nie, weil es mich selbst nicht betrofft hat,
wenig beschäftigt.
Also insofern,
Chat, vielleicht habt ihr irgendwelche Tipps
an MrGaming.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, was du machen sollst.
Außer das, was ich dir schon
gesagt habe.
Physi bringt kaum was fürs Studium.
Nee, Physi bringt nichts fürs Studium. Gar nichts.
Aber du hast eine Ausbildung, kannst
danach Geld verdienen.
Wenn du Ahnung hast.
Hat sich für dich irgendwas im Leben
geändert nach deinem signifikanten Gehaltssprung
im letzten Jahr? Nö.
Weder beim letzten signifikanten
Gehaltssprung, noch bei diesem signifikanten
Gehaltssprung. Ich mache genau das
gleiche wie vorher.
Ich sitze den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner
und lasse mein Geld
rumliegen und
gebe davon nichts aus.
Und ab und zu gebe ich mal ein bisschen was aus,
weil ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen muss. Aber
ansonsten, bei mir ändert
sich da nichts.
Ich sage doch, einmal Kellerkind, immer Kellerkind.
Also,
ich glaube,
ich glaube, es wird sich bei mir nie was ändern.
Mich kann man
wenig mit
materiellen Sachen
happy machen.
Also, wie gesagt,
die Sache, wofür ich
Geld ausgebe, ist, alle paar Jahre
mal ein ordentlich teurer
neuer Rechner.
Und wenn ich was haben will, zwischendurch
auch immer mal wieder. Ja, ich habe mir das Fahrrad
gekauft, zum Beispiel.
Oder, ja gut, letztes Jahr
habe ich erstaunlich viel ausgegeben. Letztes Jahr habe ich
mir ein Auto geholt, was
ich seit
20 Jahren oder so nicht mehr gemacht
habe.
Aber da sieht man mal auch, von welchen
Zeiträumen wir hier reden,
ja. Urlaub
juckt mich gar nicht, Autos
juckt mich gar nicht,
irgendwelche komischen
teuren Freizeitaktivitäten
juckt mich gar nicht.
Ich glaube, das Einzige, was ich letztes Jahr
für so Freizeitsachen ausgegeben habe,
also,
erstmal mal Fahrrad und so außen
vor, ja, Fahrrad ist ja auch Freizeit,
aber so, so, so, just for fun
Freizeitaktivitäten, so, war
das Iron Maiden Konzert in Frankfurt.
Ich glaube, das war das Einzige,
wo ich irgendwie, irgendwie mal hingegangen
bin, wo ich ein bisschen Kohle für ausgegeben habe.
Das neue Auto so agil wie das alte, vom Namen
her nicht, vom Auto her schon
und es ist vor allem deutlich moderner.
Nö, also, wie gesagt,
ist nichts geändert.
Die Lesung ist falsch, ja.
Bist du bei Microsoft Gold Support in Indien gelandet
wieder? Sorry for Bash.
Massive Subscription.
xxpainxx,
danke schon für den Sub.
Massive.
Ja,
das ist überall so. Dennis, danke
für den Sub. Benutzt
jemand Tastatur mit US Layout? Ne.
Da mache ich einen Bogen drum.
Das US Layout hat Theorie
theoretisch einige Vorteile, gerade wenn man
Kommandozeilen, Wim-Shortcuts
und sowas verwendet, aber
ich habe mich so sehr an das deutsche Tastatur
Layout seit klein auf gewöhnt, ich
kann da nicht umsteigen.
Oder, ich will nicht sagen, ich kann nicht
umsteigen, es ist, es ist eine
ganz gehörige Portion aus, ich will nicht
umsteigen, weil ich keinen Bock habe, mich umzugewöhnen.
Ja, ich weiß, gerade
die ganzen Klammern und so, die du auf ordentlichen
Tasten hast beim US Layout,
das macht schon Sinn, aber ich bin,
da bin ich viel zu faul, dafür mich umzugewöhnen.
Jantari, kann es sein,
dass du, dass du Daok eben spielst?
Ich habe jemand gesehen, in-game,
der hieß fast genauso.
Ne, wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich ist der Name einfach nur
mehrfach, mehrfach
belegt. Katrin, dich
habe ich letztens in-game gesehen.
Irgendwo. Ich habe dich
geändert, wirklich?
Bist du Heiler?
Ah, ne, Shami. Kann sein,
ja, habe ich schon wieder vergessen, ja,
aber, wir waren, der Name kommt
mir auch bekannt vor, ich glaube, wir waren irgendwann mal random
in irgendeiner Group, bei irgendwelchen,
auch bei irgendwelchen Raids, wo man random
Groups macht, waren wir garantiert in irgendeiner Gruppe,
der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ja.
Nice.
Chatgear.
Oh, fuck, Leute, es ist 21.30,
ich muss eine halbe Stunde pennen gehen, morgen muss ich
auf die Arbeit. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock
auf den Scheiß, Mann.
Ich weiß, dass es morgen überhaupt nicht schlimm ist,
wenn ich morgen eine halbe Stunde sitze und alles ist
wieder wie immer, ich kenne das, ja,
es war mir jedes Mal Anfang Januar so,
aber ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock drauf,
Mann. Ich sollte echt
in Altersteilzeit gehen, ey.
Gibt's da nicht irgendwie, irgendwie sowas
für Leute wie mich?
Was, wie Altersteilzeit,
nur, dass es nicht Altersteilzeit heißt?
Keck?
Keckzeit, oder?
Weiß nicht.
Kann man nicht einfach
24-7 Kreisel grinden?
Und trotzdem
fett die Kohle überwiesen bekommen?
Freu dich doch auf wie viele Meetings
und alle fragen erst mal, wie es war.
Ja, ganz schlimm, ey.
Ganz schlimm, habe ich am Anfang ja auch schon gesagt.
Bürgergeldzeit, auf geht's.
Wie ist das
eigentlich jetzt, wenn man Bürgergeld bekommt,
Leute? Dürfen die
einen immer noch zwingen zu irgendwelchen
Maßnahmen und wenn man da nicht
hingeht, kriegt man, kriegt man
das gestrichen? Oder ist es
jetzt vom Tisch?
Denke schon, oh, fuck, Alter.
Oh, shit.
Nee, dann will ich kein Bürgergeld, Mann.
Nee, ey, den Scheiß mach ich nicht.
Den Scheiß
mach ich nicht. Also mit dem Arbeitsamt will ich
nie wieder was zu tun haben, Alter. So ein Kackladen.
Soll jetzt noch schlimmer werden,
wir haben ja festgestellt, dass wir zu wenig Geld haben.
Wir könnten ja mal, ich hätte da so
einen Vorschlag, wir könnten mal
80% unserer bürokratischen
Hürden abschaffen, das würde enorm viel Geld
sparen. Kannst du
nicht da auch Gold verkaufen?
Ey, nein.
Das ist ein Free-Shard.
Erstens ist es verboten,
zweitens kauft keiner Free-Shard-Gold,
zweitens will ich das nicht und
und was, witziger
Fun-Fact, in
Season 1 hat sogar jemand mal versucht,
Gold zu verkaufen auf einem Free-Shard, Alter.
So wir.
Aber witzig war, den haben sie über
Ebay erwischt, die Mods vom
Server wurden gleich gebannt.
Bam. Bürgergeld Prime.
Ja, da bin ich auch
dabei. Mit Prime-Sub
dabei.
Mit kostenlosem Wubblor-Sub.
So, so hätte ich
das gerne. Ah ja.
Und Chat.
Was war euch sonst so
gewesen die letzten Tage?
Irgendwas
erwähnenswertes.
Ich frage jetzt nur so blöd,
weil ich habe jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit,
bevor ich ins Bett muss, beziehungsweise bevor ich ausmachen muss.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Also, es gibt was.
Nein, es gibt eigentlich nur eine Möglichkeit.
Ich bleibe jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde on, weil
es lohnt sich nicht, eine halbe Stunde auf irgendetwas anderes zu machen.
Du hast dein
ESP32C3
Super-Mini entdeckt.
Ist der C3 das mit dem neuesten Bluetooth-Zeug und
ZigBee?
Wie ich ins neue Jahr gestartet bin, wie immer.
Ich habe gewartet,
bis das Gröbste vom
Fensterwerk weg ist,
und dann bin ich pennen gegangen.
So ein bisschen wie, kennt ihr dieses Meme von dem Dicken,
der vorm Rechner sitzt und dann
was durchs Fenster scheint
und er dann böse guckt und
den Vorhang zuzieht?
So ungefähr bin ich
gestern gewesen.
Ich lieb euch mit Akschlinux.
Ja, Beste. Willkommen im Club.
Du musst das aber dann auch jedem täglich
mehrfach erzählen.
Aber kein Plan, was da so einsteigerfreundlich ist.
Die sind überhaupt nicht einsteigerfreundlich.
Wayland Desktop sieht echt
mehr... Wayland ist kein Desktop.
Also das ist
alles noch ein bisschen
durcheinander.
Ich würde dir vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Akschlinux zum Einstieg empfehlen,
weil das Beste an Akschlinux, finde ich, ist,
wenn man es minimal installiert
und den Rest selbst einrichtet.
Ja, so wie ich hier bei mir gemacht habe.
Akschlinux
I3
Westterm
Confix
Also
ich würde dir empfehlen, probiere
nochmal aus.
Also, es ist die Frage, hast du schon
Linux-Erfahrung? Wenn du nicht Linux, wenn du
keine große Linux-Erfahrung hast, dann nimm Linux Mint
und taste dich da erstmal ein bisschen ran.
Wenn du generell schon
Linux-Erfahrung hast und einfach durch ein bisschen Akschlinux
rantasten willst, dann installiere dir das doch einfach
mal in der VM und richte dir das
mal vom Scratch ein, so wie du es haben willst.
Da lernst du viel bei und dann hast du auch das
genauso, wie du es am Ende haben willst.
Ja, Beste.
So muss das sein.
Aksch, by the way.
Ja.
Du hast ja einen Plan für das neue Jahr.
Gaming, Kochen, immer vernünftiges Lernmaterial mit
eingeteilten Fachmitteln. Also,
ich habe mir nichts vorgenommen.
Ich nenne es jetzt mal so.
Aber ich habe mir nichts vorgenommen für das neue Jahr.
Ihr kennt mich, ich halte
davon nichts und
ich denke, die Statistik
gibt mir da auch recht.
Ja, gibt es auch, aber
für Desktop-Virtualisierung
ist das nichts.
Probier es mal lieber mit einer VM.
Die Statistik gibt mir da auch recht.
Neujahrsvorsätze sind Mist und halten nicht.
Was ich mir aber, ich nenne es
jetzt trotzdem mal, vorgenommen habe,
beziehungsweise eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit auch vorhabe,
ist es, weiterzumachen, regelmäßig
rennen zu gehen und Fahrrad zu fahren.
Und was ich mir auch vorgenommen habe,
aber nicht als Neujahrsvorsatz, sondern
weil ich es haben will, ist
ein neues Fahrrad kaufen. Weil mein
Fahrrad ist ja hier nicht mehr
straßentauglich, aber Heimtrainer-tauglich
glücklicherweise.
Und ich warte jetzt noch, bis es wieder was in meiner Größe
zu liefern gibt. Am besten natürlich,
wenn es das dann mit 1x12 Schaltung gibt.
Das werde ich mir irgendwann im Laufe
des nächsten Jahres dann kaufen.
Und dann wird wieder, gerade wenn es jetzt wärmer
wird, wird wieder geradelt.
Wayland ist immer
noch in der VM verbuggt. Zumindest, wenn
ich es manuell installiere mit Sway.
Wenn man offizielle
Distributionen verwendet,
wenn man den offiziellen Desktop
von Distributionen verwendet, wie
von Ubuntu oder Fedora oder so,
dann geht das auch mit Wayland.
Aber bei mir ist es verbuggt.
Und Copy-Paste
funktioniert bei mir auch beispielsweise
mit Wayland in der VM nicht richtig. Es ist alles
etwas eklig.
Ja, Hyperland ist cool, aber Hyperland ist
auf jeden Fall nichts in der VM.
Und auch was für Wayland.
Also wenn du Hyperland
verwenden willst, dann musst du es wirklich
native installieren. Das klappt in der VM
nicht richtig.
Korrekt.
Welches Linux würde sich für einen blutigen Anfänger
einführen? Ich würde tatsächlich genau das,
was MrGaming schreibt. Linux Mint
ist echt nicht verkehrt. Cinnamon Edition,
also das Standard Linux Mint, ist
wirklich einsteigertauglich.
Einsteigertauglicher
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Du hast dir vorgenommen, etwas
mehr based durch
das Jahr zu gehen. Okay.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen? Wie geht
man based durch das Jahr?
Ist das eine Umschreibung für
entspannter?
Oder was muss man machen, um
based zu werden?
Ja, habe ich jetzt, kaufe ich mir auch wieder.
Und das liegt jetzt nicht daran, weil ich
so gerne irgendwie auf
Schotterwegen fahre,
sondern weil die
Gravel-Bike-Geometrie einfach für
Noobs wie mich etwas angenehmer ist als
von einem Rennrad.
Based ist zum Beispiel zu sagen, dass man
based ist und sich weiter zu erläutern verstehe.
Ist das ein bisschen was Richtung
ähm...
Ne, fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Kann man sich irgendwie versichern gegen Unfälle? Doch.
Also,
ich bekomme das Geld von der Versicherung für das
Fahrrad, was kaputt ist, aber
die haben noch nicht bezahlt.
Ja. Warum ist das nicht mehr
straßentauglich? Hattest du es nicht erst gekauft?
Doch, aber ich wurde umgefahren auf
dem Fahrradweg. Keck wait.
Oh ne, hör mal bloß auf.
Da muss man sich ja richtig anstrengen für.
Da mache ich lieber Kreiselgrind.
Wann Viewer
radeln auf Swift?
Du wirst lachen. Ich habe es mir sogar
überlegt schon und ich wollte
tatsächlich am Wochenende es mal ausprobieren.
Allerdings nicht Viewer radeln,
sondern einfach mal eine Runde fahren, so zur Motivation
mit ein paar Leuten hier dabei.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich nicht in der Lage
bin, meinen Trainer, also meinen
Smart-Trainer über Bluetooth gescheit zu verbinden.
Ich kann ihn zwar über Bluetooth verbinden,
aber dann nur,
den Leistungsmesser
und nicht die RPM und die
was ist die andere Sache noch?
Also irgendwie hat er nur
einen Sensor von drei erkannt, was ziemlich kacke ist.
Also wahrscheinlich
ich habe einen
Wahoo Kickr Core.
Ich brauche wahrscheinlich so einen N plus Stick.
Na steuer, ich habe keinen
Controller dafür.
Ich finde
Mint ist top.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Moin, auch wieder am Start.
Normalerweise würde
ich jetzt sagen, ich freue mich, dass du wieder da bist
und wie war dein Neujahr und sowas.
Aber du weißt, ich bin kein Mann solcher
Worte.
Trotzdem schön, dass du wieder da bist.
Ich erspare dir die Fragen, auf die ich auch
keinen Bock hätte. Aber 42
Monate.
Sag mal, wie sieht es eigentlich mit Cannabis-Legalisierung
aus? Sollte
das nicht schon irgendwie
mal langsam sein?
Oder kriegen
ich das wieder nicht gebacken?
Murmel, du hast recht, du musst was trinken, ja.
Legal ist es nicht, am
Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof interessiert es aber keinen.
Ich habe euch doch erzählt, ich war letztens mit einem
Kollegen Mittagessen in Frankfurt, haben wir
Geld abgehoben am Geldautomat
und direkt neben uns stehen
drei Schwarze und dealen irgendwas.
Einfach offen
mitten auf der Straße, random, juckt einfach keiner.
Was kostet so ein
N plus
Dongle
für einen PC? Das ist ja nix,
13 Euro,
keck, wait, Alter. Das werde ich mir jetzt
gleich, Moment, Handy, Amazon App.
Bestelle ich mir jetzt gleich
ein und dann
ist gut.
N plus
Dongle, ja.
Lieferbar.
Wie, morgen ist da nix
lieferbar? Was ist mit euch los, Amazon, Mann?
Okay, Mittwoch.
Aber morgen bringt der eh nix.
Nicht N plus,
N plus.
Für meinen Smart-
Smart-Trainer, dass ich den mit dem PC verbinden kann.
Bestelle ich doch jetzt einfach mal
hier irgendwie einen von
den China-Chinesen-Dingern.
Die haben alle scheiß
Bewertungen, was ist denn das?
Was hast du denn für einen?
Den hier.
Okay, den bestelle ich jetzt
einfach. Okay.
Dann,
ach, irgend so ein Billig-Ding.
Warum gibt es da wieder so 30.000 Sachen
zur Auswahl? Was ist denn das?
Ich bestelle so ein 15 Euro Billig-Ding und gucke
einfach, ob das taugt oder nicht.
Ja.
Zack, bestellt.
Gut.
Hast du auch, hast du auch n Lüfter?
Ein Fan?
Gestern hat ein
Update erstmal meinen Arch zerstört.
Besser hätte das
ja nicht enden können.
Ja, ich hoffe, du hast n Snapshot.
Nach meinem Themaset, vielleicht sollte ich mal meinen alten
Snapshots löschen.
Den können wir jetzt wieder löschen.
Weg damit.
Ja, ich habe
so ein 14 Euro Stick gekauft.
Hast du nicht mal T-Shirts bestellt?
Wie waren die von der Qualität?
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, welche das gewesen sind.
Baderdingsbums, dankeschön für den Sub.
Weiß ich nicht mehr, welche das waren, die ich, wo ich
erzählt habe, dass ich mal hier bestellt habe.
Morgen kein Bock auf Arbeit.
Du auch nicht? Willkommen
im Club.
Viel weniger Bock kann man eigentlich gar nicht
auf irgendwas haben.
Und wie weit hat ein CR-Root dein
Arch
wieder gefixt?
Du musst fixen, dass AMD-V
wieder funktioniert. Siehst du mal,
ich hatte so lange keine
AMD-CPU. Ich weiß gar nicht, was
AMD-V ist.
Ist das jetzt Gegenstück zu VTD?
Also bei Intel ist ja VTD.
Intel?
Ah ja, okay.
Also
Virtualisierungskrempel.
Ja, okay.
Timeshift und Arch.
Timeshift ist
für mich, wenn man beim Fernseher auf Pause drücken kann
und dann vor- und zurückspulen.
Kicker Headwind. Was kostet denn das?
Da ist jetzt etwas
leicht sidetracked.
Boah!
Ein Lüfter für
313 Euro. Was ist denn mit
denen kaputt?
Also man kann es auch übertreiben, oder?
Vielleicht ist
es einfach nur bei Amazon so teuer.
Ne, da kostet es wohl ein paar Euro.
280 Euro.
Und da kostet es 230 Euro.
Aber ist trotzdem
ein krasser Preis für
einen Lüfter, ja.
Aber gut, der muss halt auch
ordentlich Luft umsetzen.
Ist
AirSync BTFS
based system? Achso.
Okay, habe ich noch nicht benutzt.
Ich mache immer AirSync.
Manuell oder automatisch.
Fertig.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das ist das Ding, dass ich hoch und runter fahren kann.
Aber ich will ja keinen neuen Trainer.
Ich habe ja schon einen.
Guts für mich erstmal.
Ja.
Jetgear.
Ich war gespannt, was 2024
so auf uns alles zukommt.
Bin mal
gespannt, was aus dem Deutschlandticket wird.
Wenn
das irgendwie abgeschafft wird,
bin ich super pisst.
Ich halte ja eh schon alle für
wahnsinnig unfähig und
das Deutschlandticket war
eigentlich die einzige Sache,
die mein Leben
von allen den Dingern,
die die letzten, keine Ahnung,
zehn Jahre oder so, da so politisch passiert sind,
wirklich mal zum Positiven
verändert hat. Spürbar.
Wenn sie das wieder abschaffen,
ey, dann bin ich echt durch mit dem ganzen Scheißladen.
Pack mich genauso ab wie die Bahn.
Was meint ihr, was passiert mit dem
Deutschlandticket? Es wird auf jeden Fall teurer.
So viel ist schon mal sicher.
Das finde ich
wiederum auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Besser ein bisschen teurer
als abschaffen.
Wenn das, man muss nämlich mal
echt sehen, das Deutschlandticket war eine wirklich
richtig riesen Verbesserung für viele
Leute. Und
gerade auch im Hinblick auf
dessen, dass du dich nicht mehr mit
irgendwelchem Verkehrsverbund-Scheiß
und so auseinandersetzen musst.
Aber mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn das
das einzig Gute, was es die letzten Jahre über in der
Richtung da Neues gegeben hat.
Wenn das nicht wieder irgendwie
abgeschafft wird und so.
Ich bin da, ich hab da,
ich hab's schon oft gesagt, ich hab da eh eigentlich schon
mehr oder weniger abgeschlossen. Ich rechne nicht damit,
dass irgendjemand irgendwas entscheidet,
was in meinem Interesse
ist, beziehungsweise
irgendwie das berücksichtigt,
was ich mir wünsche. Insofern
wird das alles wurscht.
Der Markt regelt das,
Leute, wisst ihr doch.
Mein nächstes Wahlwett schon wieder, absolut keine Ahnung,
was ich wählen soll.
Ja, das ist genau das Gleiche,
das ist halt richtig, also beim Deutschlandticket
versus früher,
da hast du halt mal den direkten Vergleich
gesehen, wie kacke das gewesen ist.
Du musstest früher teilweise gucken,
wenn du, Beispiel,
wir machen mal ein ganz konkretes Beispiel.
Als ich das letzte Mal auf der Gamescom war,
ist schon ne Weile her,
da musstest du dir in Köln
noch ne Wochenkarte holen.
Da bin ich ein Automat, hab mir ne Wochenkarte
geholt, da war schon mal gar nicht
so genau klar, welche Stufe der
Wochenkarte ich eigentlich brauche.
So, dann bin ich, dann hab ich mir
die vermeintlich richtige Stufe der Wochenkarte
geholt, und dann kam die Karte
aus dem Automat, und unten
drunter stand, nur
gültig, also ich habe diesen Automat
Geld bezahlt, und danach kam ne
Karte raus, und unten auf der
Karte stand, nur
gültig mit,
keine Ahnung, Köln ID Nummer
oder sowas. Hab ich mir
gesagt, was?
Was wollt ihr von mir? Also erstens ist es
rechtlich sicherlich fragwürdig, mich das erst
bezahlen zu lassen, und dann ist es nur gültig mit.
Was wollt ihr von mir?
Da hab ich bei der Hotline angerufen,
von dem Kölner Verkehrsverbund,
und da meinte die so, ja, das kann ich ihnen auch
nicht sagen, aber sie können ja mal hier bei uns
am Bahnhof in die
Kölner Verkehrsverbund Zentral
Dingsda Beratung gehen.
Alter, ich will einfach nur bei euch ne Woche
lang Fahrrad, ähm, ne Woche lang
mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln fahren.
Ich will keine Beratung,
ich will mich damit nicht irgendwie großartig belasten,
auseinandersetzen, ich will einfach nur ne fucking
Fahrkarte haben, die ich außerdem
schon bezahlt habe. Hab ich so nicht gesagt,
ja. Hab ich dann, bin ich, hab ich
nicht gemacht. Da hab ich mal just for fun dem Busfahrer
das gezeigt, wo wir dann eingestiegen sind,
hab ich den Busfahrer gefragt, hab ich gesagt, hier, gucken sie mal,
da gibt's unten sowas, wo da steht
nur gültig mit welcher Nummer. Ich hab gesagt, welche
Nummer denn? Ich hab mir das Ding am Bahnhof gerufen,
und er hat gesagt, ach, keine Ahnung, das versteht keiner.
Hat uns durchgewunken.
Das sind so Dinger, wo du dich
so fragst, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn,
ja?
Es wollte auch keiner irgendwas sehen von
uns. Und das sind so Sachen,
die haben das Deutschland-Ticket halt komplett, komplett
gefixt. Über die App
wollte ich das damals machen,
da musstest du dich erst umständlich
registrieren, und an jedem Registrierungs-
step bin ich als Nicht-Kölner gescheitert
damals.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dann noch irgendwie ne
Probeüberweisung machen musstest zur
Identifizierung oder so komisches Zeug,
hat zumindest einmal hingehauen.
Also, deswegen, ich hab mein
Deutschland-Ticket, auch wenn ich,
streng genommen, es sich für mich gar nicht rechnet,
für einmal die Woche fahren.
Ich wäre theoretisch sogar ein bisschen billiger,
würde ich einfach so das bezahlen.
Naja.
Nee, wär ich nicht.
Stimmt nicht, was ich sag. Ich glaube, es kostet
ja mittlerweile 18 Euro oder so
ne Tageskarte oder sowas.
Nach Frankfurt und zurück.
Wobei ich's gar nicht genau weiß. Aber das ist halt
was, was das Deutschland-Ticket komplett
gefixt hat. Und das würd mich echt
so abfacken, wenn das wieder weg ist.
Ey, ich hab noch nicht mal
vor, die zu verarschen.
Ich hab einfach nur keinen Bock mehr auf diesen ganzen
Verkehrsverbund-Shit.
Ja, ich hoffe. Ich hoffe.
Es gibt ja schon wieder
Diskussionen für nächstes Jahr, ob das
äh, also teurer wird's wahrscheinlich,
aber das versteh ich sogar noch irgendwo.
Aber die sollen das unbedingt
beibehalten.
Sollte das abgeschafft
werden, würde das, würde das
abermals, äh, mein
ja, wie soll ich sagen, mein
eh schon nicht vorhandenes Vertrauen
untergraben. Ja.
Das geht aber auch, das geht aber auch nur,
wenn der Kontrolleur nicht weiter genauer
nachguckt, oder?
Weil bei mir wollen sie oftmals,
dass man das antippt
oder hoch und runter scrollt, wollen sie
bei mir oftmals. Dass man hoch und runter scrollt.
Wobei man das beim Screenshot auch machen könnte.
Dass man hoch und runter scrollt.
Aber manche, manchmal wollten sie sogar, dass man
zurück in der App geht und sowas.
Also sie sind da schon, also ich glaube nicht, dass man dauerhaft
mit einem GIF durchkommt.
Außerdem brauchst
du ja auch ein gültiges GIF.
Gibt's da keine Scanner für?
Doch!
Doch, gibt's Scanner für.
Du musst da so eine Art QR-Code zeigen
und das scannt er dann.
Ich, da würde ich, so weit würde ich gar nicht
mal gehen, dass die ab, dass absichtlich das gemacht wird,
was mir schadet. Es ist eher so, dass ich
das Gefühl hab, es wird nichts gemacht von
dem, was mir persönlich wichtig war, beziehungsweise
wo ich sagen würde, hey, ich hab
ja nichts dagegen, hab ich ja auch nicht Steuern zu bezahlen,
aber es wäre
cool, wenn man sieht, dass von den vielen
Steuern, die ich bezahle, das ist wirklich nicht wenig,
auch ein bisschen was ankommt,
da wo ich Bock drauf hab, so.
Mal gucken, wie der Internet-Ausbau
läuft, Leute. Der Glasfaser-Ausbau.
Das wäre so ein Thema, was
mir wichtig wäre, der ja jahrelang
schleifen gelassen wurde und letztes Jahr
wurde ja angefangen, richtig Attacke zu machen.
Mit
einem, wie heißt der?
Haben sie es genannt? Mit irgendeinem Maßnahmen-
Fahrplan oder sowas?
Mit zentralem Regis-
Ne, nicht. Wie hieß das? Zentrales
Ausbau-Ding? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Davon wird wahrscheinlich eh die Hälfte dann umgesetzt.
Und mal
gespannt, wann es bei mir dann wirklich Glasfaser gibt.
Aber das frage ich mich auch,
wie das mit dem Screenshot klappen soll.
Ich würde die aber auch nicht bescheißen.
Ich finde es vollkommen gerechtfertigt, dass
die Sachen kosten, die es kostet.
Oh ne, hör mal bloß auf.
Fahrradinfrastruktur-Ausbau habe ich
das letzte Mal schon drüber aufgeregt.
Bei uns sind zwei Fahrradwege
geplant, irgendwie gefühlt seit
über zehn Jahren. Und das letzte,
was man von diesen zwei Fahrradwegen gehört hat,
also kein einfacher Fahrradweg, sondern
ein Fahrradschnellweg, nennt sich das sogar.
Das ist quasi so eine
Fahrradautobahn,
was direkt nach Frankfurt durchgeht,
wo du auch permanent quasi Vorfahrt hast
mit dem Fahrrad. Ordentlicher Fahrradweg.
Das letzte, was ich gehört habe, ist, dass
wieder eine Machbarkeit, eine erneute
Machbarkeitsstudie angefällt.
Da weißte
es geht auf jeden Fall nicht los
in nächster Zeit.
Guckt euch das an. Hanau-Frankfurt-
Fahrrad-Schnellstraße
oder so.
Warum hier?
Warum der Rad-Schnellweg?
Okay. Ja.
Hier, die zwei. Hanau-Frankfurt
nördlich des Mainz,
Hanau-Frankfurt
südlich des Mainz.
Wäre für mich persönlich mega nice.
Gerade jetzt, wo ich
mehr Fahrrad fahre.
Und das Ding ist halt, wenn man sich das
hier anschaut.
Oder hier, der Südmainz interessiert mich eigentlich mehr.
Guck mal.
Also wir sind gerade, also das Ganze
wurde
erdacht
und dann wurde 2020
muss ich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen
lassen. 2020
wurde eine Machbarkeitsstudie
in Auftrag gegeben.
Diese wurde im März
fertiggestellt. Die haben
ohne Scheiß
zweieinhalb Jahre
für die
Machbarkeitsstudie gebraucht.
Was meint ihr denn, wie lange das dauert?
Wenn die Machbarkeitsstudie schon
zweieinhalb Jahre dauert,
bis denn wirklich der Radweg überhaupt
angefangen wird zu bauen. Guck mal.
Die Aufzeichnung von einer online
Informationsveranstaltung 2012.
2012.
wurden Ziel und Vorgehen
der Machbarkeitsstudie erläutert.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das Ding, die Planung ging vor über
zwölf Jahren los. Vor über
zwölf Jahren.
Und das
krasseste, was sie bis jetzt geschafft haben
dafür ist, eine Machbarkeitsstudie
anzufertigen. Und der Witz
ist, dass der Anfang
zu bauen ist noch in
weiter Ferne.
Und das
Bauen selbst dauert genau noch mal ewig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich überhaupt
noch Fahrrad fahren kann, wenn
der fertig ist.
Aber mit sowas, es ist aber ernsthaft
so, genau mit sowas
förderst du sowas.
Genau mit sowas.
So. Mal gucken, mal gucken, wie es um den
Nordmainischen steht.
Da wurde die Machbarkeitsstudie übrigens
2019 schon veröffentlicht.
Guck mal. Hier.
Hier. Also. Alter.
Zu diesem Zweck hat die
im Februar 2016
eine Absichtserklärung unterschrieben.
Moment. Sie haben eine Absichtserklärung
unterschrieben, um eine
Machbarkeitsstudie zu erstellen.
Die haben noch nicht
die Studie erstellt. Die haben eine Absichtserklärung
unterschrieben, um eine Machbarkeitsstudie zu erstellen.
Dann wurde
dreieinhalb Jahre
später eine Machbarkeitsstudie
veröffentlicht.
So. Und jetzt
wurde im Dezember oder im
Spätsommer 2023
eine weitere Machbarkeitsstudie
Die haben sowas von
einfach nur krass den Arsch
offen in Deutschland mit Bürokratie.
Das ist nicht normal.
Ich kann kein Fahrrad mehr fahren.
Wenn der fertig ist.
Falls das jemals fertig wird.
Das kann doch nicht sein, Mann.
Sei froh, dass du in Hessen bist. Warum?
Ist das woanders?
Da war die Machbarkeitsstudie da nicht dreieinhalb, sondern
viereinhalb Jahre.
Also wisst ihr,
was ich wirklich sehr nice finden würde?
Ich würde...
What the fuck?
Ich würde sehr nice finden.
Übrigens, das ist auch eine super Sache, wo man
ein bisschen Kohle mitsparen könnte.
Unnötig die Bürokratie einfach weglassen.
Aber ich hätte...
Wisst ihr, was ich mir wünschen würde?
Was nicht passieren wird?
Wenn wir
einen sinnvollen Weg finden würden zwischen
so wie wir es in China machen
und so wie wir es jetzt machen.
In China wäre das Ding fertig in einem dreiviertel Jahr.
Einmal quer durchs Land.
Wären halt
vielleicht im Fundament ein paar Bauarbeiter
drin eingegossen worden.
Oder was auch immer sonst noch passiert.
Wäre in China...
Aber es wäre fertig gewesen.
Und bei uns ist in der Zeit
erstmal eine Absichtserklärung
zur Machbarkeitsstudie
erstellt worden.
Und es wäre mir ganz recht,
wenn wir vielleicht irgendwie sowas
schönes in der Mitte
fänden könnten.
Also finden würden.
Weil so nach dem Motto
wir machen es nicht so
billig
und
rücksichtslos,
wie es in China gemacht wird.
Aber wir machen es vielleicht auch nicht ganz so
übertrieben bürokratisch wie bei uns.
Sodass man vielleicht es schafft
in 5 Jahren hinzubekommen.
Anstatt in
40.
Ist halt echt der Witz, man.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Ich glaube es gibt kein einziges Unternehmen
was sich nicht auch über die Bürokratie aufregt.
Genau.
MrBeast soll mal in Deutschland bitte schön Fahrradwege bauen.
Excellent.
Ich subscribe dann auch auf YouTube.
Du hast es geschafft guter Dinge zu sein
für dreiviertel Tag. Nice.
Ich meine ihr dürft
nicht vergessen.
In Italien haben die es geschafft.
Ich habe vergessen wo.
Aber das ist nicht einfach nur eine popelige Brücke.
Die haben es geschafft in Italien eine
riesen Brücke zu bauen innerhalb von einem Jahr.
Wo war das denn?
Genua.
Ist das das? Ja.
Genau.
Das ist da wo die Brücke eingestürzt ist.
Das ist keine kleine Furzbrücke.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also das ist eine ordentliche Brücke.
Sowas was sie in 40 Jahren
brauchen würde wahrscheinlich.
Die haben einfach eine Brücke gebaut in einem Jahr.
Fertig. Hat funktioniert.
Nein.
Würde ich aber gerne spielen.
Aber ich spiele keine Early Access Spiele.
Ich weiß was das ist.
Das ist von den ehemaligen Siedler.
Oder nicht von den ehemaligen.
Das ist das falsche Wort.
Vom ehemaligen Siedler Erfinder.
Oder Miterfinder.
Eigentlich genau mein Spiel.
Ich warte bis das raus ist.
Ich glaube das liegt bei uns auch daran,
weil sich keiner so wirklich für das Gesamte interessiert.
Sondern genau für seinen sehr überschaubaren
Horizont, wenn es um bürokratische
Äkte geht in Deutschland.
Richtig. Genau.
Die haben massig Verlust gemacht.
Gerade die Händler
und Geschäftsbesitzer sind ja den Bürgermeister
da quasi auf der...
Die haben schon quasi bei dem im Wohnzimmer gesessen,
wann es endlich wieder los geht.
Der hatte gewissen Druck dahinter.
Aber bei uns passiert das auch nicht.
Trotzdem.
Bei uns dauert sowas 30 Jahre.
Was macht eigentlich Stuttgart 21,
wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Nein ist es nicht.
Wenn es fertig wäre hätten wir das schon mitgekriegt.
Ich schau nicht nach.
Aber das mit dem Fahrradweg
das triggert mich jedes Mal,
wenn das mir einer erzählt.
Oh.
Jetzt habe ich mich aufgeregt über den Fahrradweg.
Und zack.
Boom.
Es ist 22.05 Uhr, Leute.
Ihr wisst, was das heißt.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt
Bett gehen
und morgen früh aufstehen
und auf die Arbeit fahren.
Obwohl ich gar keinen Bock habe.
Ne.
Ich trink keinen Kaffee.
Das geht auch so.
Also, Leute. Wir sehen uns morgen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.